on d uh e5 whereas black can you know
start hopping on the light squares there
i could see i could see some opposite
bishop
um domination here for for paravian
and oh that is interesting surgically
removed it is a hair twirler i didn't
notice that until today that reminds me
of absolutely is playing josh friedel
riddell i'm thinking the exact thing
that's not okay that that's not that
common it's not uncommon either but
that's that's noticeable i never knew
that you never played the other one i
have played anthopov yes the hair yeah
antipav is a is a
notorious hair twirler
you yeah
hmm 93 so the knight has
made its way out of d6
there is no immediate
anything a white's still pretty solid
so this is going to take some i think
this is i think this is really really
bad for white white is solid but at any
moment the knight i we are going to see
knight g2 f4 maybe knight t5 and i think
it's going to be
determined black's light squid bishop
versus white's dark square bishop and
often an opposite bishops one side has a
huge upper hand especially with all the
pieces on the board and the king king's
a little bit exposed
yeah well the queens on the board
opposite clark bishop positions are
a different animal completely from
queenless positions where
the presence of opposite colored bishop
gives the position a drawish flavor
so does he play c4 to close the center
and then maybe slam a knight onto d5
yeah
but you you get
you did allow this though
i don't i think you can play around it
you did allow it but
i still think this is like i think this
is completely losing
for uh
white practically i think white's i
think black is just going to execute a
light squared plan all the piece on
light squares you can allow a bishop on
d6 you're going to put your pawn
uh on f5 move it to f4 bishop or knight
on d5 bring another knight to e6 and
slowly slowly put all your piece on
light squares
and i don't see how
white can
okay well well this is what you have to
do to
get out of such positions but
take it
and he's got 10 seconds on top of
everything else
you see
[Music]
i mean knight takes c4 should be
seriously considered here because bishop
on d6 isn't that good deadly
yeah
no it's not it looks pretty but
that's about it like what fedor is doing
because it was i think the only chance
to try to like
stop black from just completely taking
over was to sack the pawn and and get
uh get some blockades in
[Music]
okay so queen c2 now the interesting
thing is you might not even have to
defend the pawn you might want to give
it away in order to open up the diagonal
but you have to be careful about how you
do it
because if white takes it with check and
then pushes d5 that's when things can
get a little bit hairy eric i'm
sensing that this game is far from over
i have a feeling that fetishive is going
to get out of this one
i just have that that sense you know
i still think blackstone come out ahead
but i definitely believe there there's
some momentum and i i see why
there there's chances for fedocide to
come back so the king on h8 seems really
safe to me this is the thing that i i
think the light squares are still going
to be this long-term problem
that was a great move by paraguay
because she's weaponizing the queen
trade quick queen h7
i was saying black can play rook g7 rep
oh seven
okay because i think the on d6 is
just being ignored and then on g2 is
also kind of okay now now that's
improvement bishop not invited to the
party no it's not
okay but you need to preserve this pawn
you don't want to give it away
knight f4 rook g2 is there f3 f3 rook g6
fe and rook f1 is threatened i think
that might win
no f3 queen takes after me
no but you can speak on h6 and play rook
f6 maybe oh yeah there is queen f3 too
five seconds
where's the win is it f3
oh my god did the tables just turn
i think your prediction is uh
it's looking it's looking good because
after kingdom one
king f2 king
i thought he was gonna play king f2 he's
walking on hot coals here king f2 you
gotta blockade the pawn there it is
three three result game here oh i could
totally win this
rook g3 i mean if i just say it was
playing for a winnow he i would have
sacked the exchange i would have sacked
the exchange on f3 i would still do it
trades
i would still do it
just gotta make a move two seconds for
vladimir rook f1 he's prepping the
exchange now he's preparing the exchange
sack yep
will he do it no he won't rookie to
check
ricky tuck was good there that was that
was a big moment to play rookie too
i think
black is okay with this actually this
could be a draw just because of the
intense light square blockade take it
perravian's still playing for a win
maybe
yeah the adrenaline hasn't worn off
no it has not king takes seven three
king g3
just king of three me rook d4 and it's
just a draw now i don't know that
peruvian is playing
that's the exchange the problem is
black's pieces are so well positioned
here
that fettuc just might not be able to
make progress
in fact king e4 p4 yep
and uh time to offer a draw
oh what a tricky move though
wait up king g2 he put his rook on the
worst possible square
now you can bring your king up and push
the h pawn six no
you can just walk walk walk the king and
pawn down it's over the bishop is
perfectly positioned the pawn promotes
and black is not in time
easy king h5
or king f5
or wait that was wrong apparently i
don't see why but king h5 would have
avoided the check because now black can
take on e5 and then they can play rookie
king h5 was the winning move bishop
seven and the rook anywhere but g7
bishop e7 bishop f8 no it doesn't rock
a7 yeah
yeah he's gotta try it though bishop e7
king e6
and david perrault
saves the game a fair result eric if
fedex would have won that
that would have been nuts
that was a really good rapid game just
overall that was i was like both players
uh got their moves in and then it swung
back and forth but
you could feel like they had the zen in
the position they could feel
feel the moment
and alexi in the meantime has
it seems outplayed alexander grishook
yeah it should be losing
but what haven't we seen you know we're
good and then you go for the king end
game you just take and play king d6 oh
king d6 is a dagger
it's over
serrano wins
he's just gonna take all the puns and
promote the b-pawn yeah who do you think
he's gonna win the pawn race eric
[Laughter]
well you you don't even
like
you have this pawn on h5 fixing both of
black spawns so it's yeah it's not even
close
it's a deep freeze
sorana wins
another bloody round with only one draw
so far out of eight games
how do you like that
no i like it i just got distracted by
the twitch chat which is always a bad
thing like do you twirl your hair more
when you're in time trouble does the
does the pace speed up i was just
thinking about that but
i was a little distracted
like what happens in a time scramble if
you're a hair twirler
yeah do you how do you
how do you negotiate
the
oh look at the final position from the
hikaru game
i mean this tells you all you need
oh
we have a ko button reserved for
positions like this uh dania that that
is a smothered mate
in the rcc
but
this th this cannot happen like you
cannot expect to beat
anybody if you're playing he takes out
five and
parham's got to find a way to put it
put it behind him trust me the problem
is it's so hard to recover when when
you're playing your car in the hole as
well like that's where it's like you're
getting depressing thoughts like a good
start's pretty important um
[Music]
the pressure of playing your car was one
thing now you have the pressure of just
trying to win
when on demand which is just yeah just
chest pressure but like
knight h4 i i um
you're playing this position hukaru has
opened up the jeep file he's indicating
he wants to attack you have an
opportunity to neutralize that by
trading the queens
and going to the end game where black's
pawn structure isn't so bad it's not
that's better
yeah yeah yeah well that's that's also
the thing once you just look at the
position
um your car has invested a bunch of time
on on this attack get the queens off and
your knights become very active right
here on g3 and h4 it looks like a
position your car would have with black
in the end and then you like right loses
knights and forks you to death
you're right in eight different places
but
parham
complete total mental breakdown he loses
the first game
we've got a draw in federation a roller
coaster of a game and demetria and
draken let's also not forget he
blundered a piece
he has a must-win with black against
motorbike that
you could not think of a more nightmare
situation than that
maybe hikaru in a must-win situation
yeah but that's it
jeez
deep breath deep breath what haven't we
seen well we haven't seen a player
profile for david paravian yet uh he's a
player eric that that
everybody's heard of him but
you know people don't realize how good
he is he's only 24 he's been around
forever
became a gm
five years ago now
i remember when he was an untitled 2400
i played a blitz tournament with him
um
he destroys me on the white side of a
king's indian and some people you play
and you just know they're going to
become a gm
he's a classic example of that so it's
good to see him flourishing
we'll pause the clock with one second
left that's an orbiter for a queen
still flags
i see
he's got a flare for the trollish
yeah i've been playing parovian and
serena those guys are
are online all the time played them so
many times in the last year or two years
they're seemingly
getting better but also also just
playing everything and
um
just a very consistent model of good
good speed chess could wrap the chest um
they they know how to fight from bad
positions
and we saw fedozeev demonstrate that in
the last game that was really really
good
um
what he recovered from
and
parham better have something up his
sleeve here because hikaru
to my knowledge has never lost a game in
this line it is incredibly drawish
and
you need some heavy duty preparation
if you are to
generate winning
he prepared 30 moves when i played him a
couple weeks ago the entire game was
prepared
in an open uh spanish
um but even if he is really well
prepared here as you mentioned hikaru is
well prepared and he has experience
so it'd be surprising if parham gets
anything substantial here
um
[Music]
against ikaru
it's a forcing it's a forcing line
relatively forcing
so if you don't have if you you don't
come up with an idea or a push
it quickly fizzles out to a dead draw
so this could mean
pretty soon
really the only way that white gets an
edge here either you win the c pawn
right because if the c pawn is traded
for the b pawn you might as well sign
the piece of chords
or if you can get black to take with an
e pawn
for instance if you get this position
you know you could make a claim that
white is better you get the d4 square
pawn is weak
you got you have the two bishops so
obviously white's not risking but
i'm not buying it eric i just i don't
see hikaru losing here
i i agree with you there and parham is
already thinking which means he's kind
of uh out of his uh knowledge base
or he's in his knowledge base and he
recognizes that everything leads to a
draw here and that can be a very
depressing uh thought and feeling so
i will say
i don't like the opening choice for a
must-win game
agreed completely
and we will monitor parham's attempts to
win on demand
for now
let's see what dimitri and draken has
cooked up
in his must-win situation of the black
pieces unsurprisingly it is a sicilian
and many years ago my coach i mean the
common advice is that when you need a
draw you play for a win right if you
modify your style that's the best way to
lose a game
which in which you're satisfied for a
draw and that's exactly what notable is
doing going straight for the open
i'm hearing there might be a disconnect
right now uh dania oh hicaro can we
check the uh hikaru game for a moment
yes we can
but the thing about this is
you have nine minutes to reconnect
right it's not like those situations
where if you aren't present for a minute
you flag
so
[Music]
i think either way he should be he's
back able to reconnect yeah that fiber
internet coming in handy yes
yes
yeah i hope you have that in canada
right
uh in some parts but honestly not
everywhere canada's uh pretty bad
infrastructure-wise when it comes to
internet um i pretty bad is probably an
understatement that it's awful in canada
want me to make you super jealous and
it's expensive
uh yes please make me jealous
so a t came out with five gig
it's sort of a trial thing in about four
cities
and one of them happened to be charlotte
that makes sense because i was like a
banking tech cub up and coming but yeah
it's home of streamers five gig
we don't even have one gig in most of
the country
in many most places even 500 megabytes
is a dream
um it's
but it's good enough elon to save us
well yeah upload speed matters more i
guess
that's the thing people don't realize
like i hate it when people say they have
one gig internet and then i test the
upload speed and it's i can't stream on
5 mbps all about the upload
but yeah i don't care we are in the one
industry where that's important
okay back to on draken's game
and we have this crazy rouser no this is
the taiman of
and dimitri has
opened the
a file but you can't really exploit it
easily right queen a5 always runs into
knight b3
yes
so
what do you make of this who's who's
better
um
white i think uh andreikin i mean his
weakness uh has always been openings
like relatively speaking like he's not
the strongest theoretician he's a very
strong practical player norderbeck is is
very good with white in the sicilians
and he also has that one point lead i
i i think i think he's just gonna be a
lot more comfortable playing an open
sicilian
than on draken
um both both because he's a more active
tournament player both because he's like
working on openings more and then just
how the the first game went
um
yeah i
on draken can run into problems with
black he has that tendency because he
has a fairly limited repertoire
when it when it comes to
his openings so
i definitely give that category to
uh notre back openings you should 100 be
uh you'll give favor you'll give him the
nod a clear a clear nod and and yeah
he's only getting stronger
yeah he's um
well the thing is as i look at this
position though
i'll push back a little bit i think
dimitri is
doing a good job of whipping up
serious queen side play he is
threatening this classic exchange sack
on c3
and notable has many ways to defend
against that one move that comes to mind
is something of a prophylactic variety
like bishop c1
i like bishop c1
yeah i mean
like um
[Music]
i'm not sure if black's going to be
castling here i'm just looking at
position and it's like okay like
i think i think he's kind of uh banking
on something happening on the queen side
because once you play this pont h5 which
we have in the game
means that when white goes g4 you get a
[Music]
they come through pretty quickly and so
i think on draken's definitely uh
looking to fish around and and find
some some opening on the queen side here
and and play from that because you just
try to castle i think g4 comes and then
you're in for some yeah you're you're
operating on borrowed time here
i mean eventually white's just gonna
play g4 anyway or something's going to
give
if black dilly dallies
you're waiting for moves like rook d2 or
maybe that rook c3 right let's say rook
hd2 then rook c390 for stuff
yeah there's a lot of tricks and traps
but my guess is dimitri will probably
default to bishop e7 if he doesn't
figure out a move
but i i think notre back seems to have
this under control
his experience level as you said his
tactical vision
are superb and you know dimitri is going
to have to pull a rabbit out of the hat
here
um in the meantime we have okay
grisrick's in an in a slightly better
end game
where should we go
uh
picardo's game
yeah i agree i think farhom is
not doing the greatest job of generating
winning chances here
uh i was not even close i would lose
this to ricardo because he's gonna get
the knights on dangerous squares
590 294 yes yes
somehow he just coordinated yeah you
passed on but it gets blockaded easily
so
that's another thing like i can't tell
you how many times i've gotten a passer
to like c7 in the middle game or two
passers they'll be on d6 and c7 somehow
they're magically blockaded and they
never go anywhere
yeah
i was really good at blockading it's
it's a
very very good at understanding how to
do that and
and and when it's good and when it's not
and just playing around it and luring
you into a false sense of uh security
the passpond is not an asset when you
play your car someone's just like you
expend all your resources pushing it and
just get
tricked somewhere else
so does he take out f3 here's the
question this is a
what about decision maybe just knight
knight ef5
and then you can prepare moves like i
don't know queen uh a5 next for example
yeah and you can't move the bishop so
you have this on on tap whenever you
want it unpleasant right you have so
many loose pieces here as well it's
worse you have to expend a lot of energy
there
but this was a half-hearted
winning attempt by parham i it did not
seem like he had serious preparation in
this line
to be completely honest
no and so can't it's
i mean that's one of the lines he
he really knows well
like right
um
and he's probably more warmed up there
but yeah that's that's as i said
preparation is going to be a factor
today people take these rabbit games
very seriously you're going to see
professional openings and this is going
to be a very professional hold by hikaru
uh from what i'm expecting here
yeah i mean he can probably the frustr
the annoying thing is that knight f3
meets with queen takes tiffany and this
end game is drawn
but will hikaru go for this i mean maybe
there's an inkling of hope for white due
to the passer i don't think so though
it's total blockade it's a dead draw i
think he car is going to go for this and
yeah he is yeah i i don't know why not
why seek adventures right yeah
why seek adventure adventurous icaru
knight c6 and
you can bring the king in
just just uh a blockaded pass pawn is
there's just gonna be almost even a
target there yeah
easy draw coffee be happy yeah he takes
this one is in the bag for mr nakamura
and he will advance to the winner's
bracket
with parham
we'll have his work cut out for him in
the comments
yeah go ahead no no i agree
no just with his last move f6 it's clear
he's probably gonna
try to bring his king maybe to d5 if he
can play e5 next but uh
yeah i mean um
let's say parham goes knights uh let's
say e5 knight c4 you just have what
knight d4
oh he won 95
some tricks have five nine
six but okay
some tricks
maybe for that reason you make some
additional
luft
and he does
and
i'm sure there's a four straw here
somewhere
probably
seven probably of knight d7
oh and then f5
look at you
night let me let's pull up in an l sport
this is really cool knight d7 shows the
importance of liquidation 97 rook d4
not knight takes rook c4 probably still
a draw
but
not worth it
and it's on the board but rook d4 f5
boom boom can't defend the pawn
time to sign the piece
yeah
okay
this one's over let's see if hikaru
finds f5 what do you think he doesn't
usually find such moves no
well let's say you don't find that f5
uh
almost out of rook c7 but no he's gonna
find that f5
yeah he's double triple checking it
there it is
and i think parham's facial expression
says
is worth a thousand words the thing is i
mean hikaru like wasn't under pressure
from the opening his body language like
he he knows he's not going to lose the
game like so it's a matter of almost
like it's like puzzle rush he just knows
the position is equal he just needs to
find the right move
there's no real mystery there
to to for what to do he knows he's in a
good position in studied position
equal position and that his opponent
doesn't really have anything there so
it's just a matter of
of the x's and o's
you didn't really have to like you
didn't have to work hard at all
um and that's so person look at what he
just did right very easy to ignore that
moment
ever i would have taken on c5 and gone
rook c4 is there anything wrong with
this absolutely not but he goes rook c6
because he's going to go king of f8 and
it will be par hum who will have to make
the draw he offers one icaru accepts and
he is through to the next round
which means we are switching
for a second back to notre back's game
which is getting crazy
whoa and draken's better
uh
much better
this is one ugly pawn structure and uh i
guess his fishing worked he got
something
he's going to win he's going to win the
exchange here uh dania if brook d3
knight f2 and otherwise you're going to
take c3
and then black's going to have
i mean this pawn structure is just awful
and black is up upon currently
my goodness
knight c5
it's brutal it's yeah but i think i
think i feel like motorbike will hold
this
i'm gonna have to take the other side
you were um
[Music]
hey i'm one for one
am i not yes well he didn't win but
i thought you were actually looking
fedocide was going to win which almost
happened i was like that would have been
like
um
but yeah you think you think notably
will hold this i'm predicting a draw in
this game the thing is he definitely
doesn't get phased by bad positions the
uzbek kids are just like they get a bad
position they just play it like like
nothing happened and they don't get like
frustrated or something so no he's
mentally very strong so i i
i can see where you're coming from
i mean how many title twos they say one
on the man in the last round
countless
and his rcc performance has been
obviously
simply outstanding ooh apparently you're
not staying you're not happy with that
move because now i probably play f6 and
i do not just have h3 hanging at the end
f6 straight away it's on the board and
this pawn structure i mean you're going
to lose the pawn races
so what should he have done c takes d3
yes
yeah
d3 and then king b2 and pawn to d4
yeah that was a weird lapse by notre
beck
but why is this so bad takes you want to
take right mm-hmm
i'm just thinking better
just think that a race is likely not
going to favor you even if you hold it
um
it's a moot point he's
he's taken on f5 and gone g4
yeah well now yeah
ugly puns so take on g4 once
probably play knight d6 knight c4
bring the king in target the g4 pawn
push your pawns white stubbled c pawns
are going to be very it's good it's
going to take a lot of labor
to get those pawns tracking down
yeah the one redeeming thing for white
is if you can take on a6 you'll have the
potential to give your knight away
for two of black spawns obviously that's
much easier said than done and
black needs to engineer
the pawn push such that
that can't happen let's see if dimitri
has that technique and rookie is a great
move limiting the knight attacking c3 my
prediction has not aged well it's
although hey
we've seen crazier things in our in our
lives haven't we
we have
but uh
the
uh peruvian fetusee of
has been very very even i i think it's
almost guaranteed that it will end in a
draw
um
should we pop into the grocery game or
do you sure
no we can check in on grishok
yeah not sir he's in a muslim commentary
with bad players but
must win situation right
and he's doing a pretty darn good job of
it as well he is this is
for muslim game you got the bishop
versus the night you got the better
pawns
this is a this is a serious push and uh
if you're going to advance to this
tournament you got to be banking on
winning positions like this i mean
so
it's just whether he's up to task or not
um
the winning technique i mean i'm not
it's not a winning position maybe yet
but i think it's actually
pretty bad for
okay he's going to go bishop a5 very he
is going he is going for it so so knight
f6
knight the downside is he weak in d5
exactly
so why did he go for this bishop a5 king
b7 then i'm going to
before
if rookie seven i have maybe bishop d8
ah then rick d7
yeah it gets very concrete here maybe
not can you go right and then i take on
f6 right and i can play the king and
pawn end game
oh also i have maybe b5
yeah beat
do you usually go but bishop d a look
good but maybe b5 as well but they've
gone a slightly different route bishop
c3 rather than the check
i mean there were two approaches
for this otherwise you can just slowly
play the position your bishop does get
stronger you can still improve your king
improve a couple pawns maybe f4 this is
more committal by giving the d5 square
but
if it works it works and and i trust
i mean he's not one to mess up technical
positions so much in terms of
understanding and and he feels like here
there's a breakthrough uh somewhere
i'm a little surprised save drew by the
way
uh so they will move to an armageddon
all right
you're surprised at grishiks i saw this
this method of conversion when you can
still slow play it and still make this
decision later you probably could still
get this position later if the
natural way of like opening things up
didn't work
because i just don't like giving the d5
square for the knight that is a huge
square but you don't want to rush it
because then because you can get in time
trouble and then nights get tricky and
then nights get tricky then you get
forked and then you
regret everything you've done
yes
i think alexi smells
the turn of the tables f4 a committal
move in his own right yep
wow
is he setting up some sort of e4 ideas
for later
hard to say
tossing the ball back into grishok's
court both sides at a minute here we go
we're in for a treat
oh i think what alexis is trying to do
is he against bishop takes a5 king b7 b4
in that case he was preparing the movie
for
and that seems pretty smart
but this g4 move looks great
i love the g4 move
um
yeah richard play if black takes
that pawn on e5 is isolated if they
don't take
um
[Music]
the pawn push could be useful in some
future races
gaining some space
and dislodging the knight is a big trump
card so g5 g5 knight t5
bishop d2 and then i want to go king e4
uh d3 to e4 well and first of all you're
threatening rook d7 check there
that's what i'm thinking maybe rookie 7
but
i don't know and i agree with you that
the great thing about playing g5 is the
black knight will not be able to return
to f6 when the white king is on e4
but grishok his clock is dwindling he's
down below 30 seconds
and
like you said black as a knight doesn't
matter what the objective evaluation is
it's going to be tricky for the rest of
the game
grif wants to be under 30 seconds now
he's in his element
drake and blunder tonight
oh my god we have to go back to that
game what just happened
oh
oh my god eric
oh he blundered a knight you're killing
me on the this killing me in the bets
here on draken
simply unbelievable i don't think i've
ever seen in blunder like this once
for him to do this twice is
is is
apocalyptic
tough day in the office though oh and
look at alexis serrano sacrificing the
pawnship bishop d4 but now he's going
all in and then grishok is close to
winning as long as he doesn't panic
that pawn can be corralled the material
advantage is going to speak for itself
okay
check
but it doesn't do anything right
but f2 is a huge threat and king f2
knight d3 track king f1 king f1 exactly
rook f4 though and alexis district
college there's bishop e3 oh
what's this move here one second
holy smokes he's completely winning i
mean he's just gonna vacuum up all of
black's pawns
take some rock d7
king f2 now
first okay this this works
g5
rookie four alexi winning h4 but i don't
know why grishok didn't
should have played king f2 there or
something he should have ignored h5
it's still winning i think uh
practically speaking rook b7 and a5 yes
no king takes c5
what's going on
g6 and rook g8 and g7 quickly
yes yes but the issue is that the black
king is just going to chill on bc
because you don't you don't have a c
pawn you have the right yeah you don't
have a pawn that can kick the king out
after kids it's just a draw oh my god
and alexi's gonna save it just move your
rook
rook g6 anything
that's it
oh my god wait whoa
oh the king can hide on the h file
the king can head on the h file oh
because black has the h pawn oh so
there's no checks that's what he was
going for alexi had to push his pawn
rather than procrastinating oh
he is upset
what a devil this alexander grisham just
look fate and rook h2 or anything just
take with the king don't take with the
rook
h2 no we have another armageddon
how did he do that i thought it was
already over that's what grishik was
going for
oh my lands and here just go h4
that's it h3 that's why you keep playing
four stroke h8
that is why you keep and that's an
immediate it's an immediate draw there
it's not even the magic
nothing oh yeah that's the match right
there that could be a ten thousand
twenty thousand dollar decision right oh
alexis serrano
is gonna have devastated recover for the
armageddon game i don't know how much
time they have in between games but that
is a tough one to shake off
it is and alexander grishard has all the
momentum right now he is back from the
dead he's climbed out of his grave he
has exited the cemetery
and he's right there in the thick of
things they're bidding for for the time
so we have two armageddon games
with andre can uh
uh with uh ferasev and paravian making
two draws
and alexander grishik
winning on demand against alexis serrano
this is going to be hard to decide
between
both of these are going to be epic
yeah we got uh
two russian armageddons right
yeah
indeed very competitive very competitive
matches
would have blundered two pieces i would
have been shocked
it's one thing he doesn't do he openings
can be a problem and and whatnot but
like he is a model of consistency when
it comes to just playing with tempo and
playing good
speed chess moves it's a very good
example for people who fall in terms of
practical skills
and he doesn't often he just yeah
doesn't fall for for tricks and stuff
like that and today
they just
something was off
yeah i was talking on stream a couple
days ago about how to define bad form
for people who aren't necessarily
experience the chess
and there's just days when you don't see
the board properly you just feel it in
your
brain
and your bones but it's it's hard to
explain what that feeling entails it's a
feeling that you're not in control of
the game that at any moment you can
blunder right
absolutely
the redeeming
idea there is at least everybody has
those days including magnus but it is it
is frustrating that's why
yeah
um it happens to everybody it happens to
everybody but
but that's why we have doubled
during the big moments and that's what
we have double elimination you you yeah
that's why sometimes like if i play a
bad game and i and i escape and i win it
i i feel good like i played bad the
result mattered i got the bad moves out
next day
new day
i'll be back in form but everybody has
those days and today dimitri andre you
can just gonna
have to ignore that and uh
get a good night's sleep and be ready
for the losers bracket
indeed and
speaking of brackets as the players bid
for the time we have a couple of updates
in our winner's bracket we see jeffrey
zhang will face wesley soap that's going
to be an epic match nepo against dubov
and of course the other two matchups are
yet to be decided
by the outcome of the armageddon hikaru
will face the winner of the serrano
grishok armageddon
and um
notre back will face the winner of
barravian so we've got more
mouthwatering matchups ahead
and right now
we have updates on the armageddon it
appears that alexander grishock will
have the black pieces
with 7 minutes and 15 seconds to alexis
serrano's 10 minutes
what do you make of that oh i mean uh
krishna gets in time trouble anyway so
why doesn't it
right like just take a minute just get
it over
exactly so that that
i'm actually surprised he didn't bid
less just to make sure he got it but
maybe i don't know if the players know
what other people
bid or if there's like data on that like
what the sweet spot is but uh it seems
like seven minutes is the range right
that's where
if you bid six minutes you're guaranteed
blocked if you bid seven minutes it kind
of depends where you fall
uh in that range
yeah that that that seems to be the
sweet spot there's there's a certain
ring to that number it's not
too high it's not too low
alexi been nine minutes so he really
wanted white
he wants to put that time pressure on
sasha and with no increment i think that
decision makes sense from his
perspective
probably mutually beneficial
and of course i mean sasha did lose with
black but
yeah i'm sure as a world-class player he
knows like he's drawn the world
champions with black and and on demand
that that when the moment comes he can
do it in the in this match as well
yeah lexi well known
for his opening preparation which is
stellar and
dangerous he's a 1d4 player almost
exclusively
so alexander grishok
probably spending some time trying to
decide
whether to play the same queen's gamma
decline from game one or
to deviate i don't really see a point in
deviating i mean the end game that they
had in game one was pretty much equal i
don't think grishik would mind
taking another stab at that
so
uh we also have updates
in
the other
match it appears that fedesav and
paravian are bidding
right now
we have some players that we have some
players that advance
that want to join in on the bidding
anyways
they don't have a match but they want a
bid and they wanna that's adorable
that's adorable nutterback was bidding
on the time uh notrebek uh i'd like to
remind you that you you won
uh might not have realized that one and
a half
that's really funny
now it is david paravian who has to do
the bidding
and knowing vladimir vladimir will
probably want the white pieces
because he's another one of those
incredibly explosive players
who likes having time on his clock
and doesn't mind
needing to win
wow it's good that we get a chance to
breathe though
isn't it
yep at last run we had one armageddon
this one they're both gonna be at the
same time so it could get pretty chaotic
somebody
two two players are being sent down to
the losers bracket
yeah and and
i've had
one experience with double elimination
was the bullet championship
and it definitely
you know winning the entire losers
bracket is a monumental task
but someone's going to do it
so
perhaps that is how dimitria and draken
is consoling himself it'll be a new day
he'll clean out the memory of this
terrible series of games and
he's very much capable of making a
comeback i think
i agree um
yeah level was unrecognizable today but
uh
all the players that have made it
especially through the rcc standings i
mean they were very very consistent they
can have updates but just over a larger
period
they are they've shown to be consistent
and you know lead rapid players and and
you give on draken a second chance
you know there's a very good chance he's
gonna show up and play at that world
class rapid level he's not going to have
two bad days
yeah i mean
one of the fascinating things about
chess is the fact that
you know on any given day even the
greatest players just have these lapses
and
a lot of people who are new to chess you
know they don't
fully
understand the truth of that statement
it's incredibly rare
but it happens and just like steph curry
could go
oh of 16 on three-pointers
um
you know no matter how incredibly good
you are you're human
but then you always remember though like
those players can go for 16 but you
remember they're they're top class
they're they're they're ceiling and the
ceiling for someone like on draken is
someone who's capable of winning that
loser's bracket he has the the acumen um
he's got the pedigree um so so because
there are some players here where
they're playing the rcc knockout and
if they do well here that might be the
best rapid result they've ever had in
their career someone like andre can he's
pretty seasoned he's had some big rapid
results both online and in person so we
know he's capable there are some other
players that this is going to be more
unknown territory they're going to have
some more
more nerves involved and more new
territory
and
remains to be seen what that ceiling is
but
but you have some players here yeah they
can win the world rapid championships
they definitely can on another player
of course is alexis serrano who's about
to play in armageddon
with alexander grishok at 22 years old
russian higher league champion in 2019
that is not an easy tournament to win
and
gold with russia in the
olympiad the previous olympiad
i didn't notice that he always is his
left hand on his cheek but that's
an interesting observation
like it's so cool like i just
in russia they they called the higher
league they had the russian championship
but somehow winning the higher league
because it's russia sounds more
prestigious like it sounds like
like like crazy strong you just i just
think of like some remote like russian
outposts and they're just playing for
like
you know two weeks and then you win the
higher league you you you you win the
test you pass the test like it is a very
serious event goryetzkina i think
she won it the other year or if she was
big yeah i i think she did and the games
have begun by the way
that's a historical result in in uh in
terms of women in chess what she was
able to do there
absolutely
and
i guess uh the question is answered they
are repeating
the exact same opening
ooh
did grisha do no he did not oh
they're not repeating but they are uh
they are in familiar territory
jeez castle's queen side oh my lance but
it's it's fairly safe there's no
no more pieces for black to bring in yet
that can
you sure about that contribute well
how about this line rookie six
queen g7
you want to stack the queen yes yes
bang bang bang
mate um actually rookie six
isn't just a gimmick move i think that
might be the move
and he plays it
okay so what i'm going to do because i'm
afraid as i probably will
we'll go rook d2 but then i have to
follow up with like 92 or something
rookie 2 and 92 and f3 maybe that's a
bit off let me think this is this is
scary
yes it is because there's also tons of
perpetual how about this
okay
now is f3 too slow f3 rook b6 queen f2
f3 i was thinking of rook's c6 but then
you could play knight e2 92 then i'd go
92 at least i have a better version or
even potentially queen e1 in some lines
but although
even bishop g6 here just preserving
the
i agree i agree the queen on b4 is very
well placed
knight d7 b6 c4 is coming and the
biggest problem is just to me that the
black's king is very comfortable on d8
so there isn't even a big hurry for
sasha here
okay there is on the clock but not on
the board
rookie two played
well it's understandable that serena
went for this though i mean he probably
knows yeah black if they play well
they're well prepared which seems to be
they have a good position or they have a
decent position but at the end of the
day he needs to find something that
gives him winning chances
and does this position give both players
winning chances yeah
black could be overextended black skin
could end up being vulnerable this is a
position from which you can play for a
win for either side and an armageddon
game yeah for some players that's how
you do it
well we can briefly check into
the other game since this one has
somewhat stabilized for now
this is fedesev who has the white pieces
against paragon barrabian started with
658 so
really going low
insisting on playing black
oh did he blunder knight f7
yes
he did didn't he
yes and f7 is cr is a crusher
bang bang bang and he might have
forgotten that the knight on c4 attacks
d2 vladimir putin is not going to miss
that
and he doesn't
that's a brutal blunder because you you
only lose a pawn your pawn structure
gets ruined a bit and you lose your
bishop
your dark squared bishop you have no
more dark squares for the rest of the
game almost
the pin is a two-sided device i think a
lot of people forget that it can be
turned around in rare cases
against the side
that imposes the pin and this is a great
example of that especially when the
pinned piece
is undefended like this because if you
take the knight
white takes the bishop and it's over
brutal
absolutely brutal
so you probably you probably go for this
or you're just going to be down upon an
end game
which is pretty depressing
but
maybe you get some holding chances some
rook end game you figure out something
but
i expect fedor save with the two minutes
an extra pawn to
smoothly convert this
and that shouldn't say smart it's never
smooth there's big stakes here i
shouldn't say smooth we've seen things
change in this match
and
both players are fighters very strong
practical players so
knight f4 is a nice move by david trying
to complicate the game i'm trying to
figure out if bishop f3 can
preserve all of the pluses of white's
position
that needs to be calculated so bishop
tell me what happens
oh it works it works if knight i have a
move for you knight takes d4
oh my
you're trying to knight d2 knight f3
then knight e2 knight g3
but i'm gonna take
oh what are you doing
i'm taking the bishop or the knight
and if rook c4 i'm going to take the
knight and go bishop d5
and again it all stems from that king it
stems from the pawn and f7 being gone
which is the irony of it but fetish of
going
a different route going greedy
and taking a second pawn
okay that gives black a little hope
might be banking on bishop f3 right now
maybe
has to be what do you think
bishop f3 is going to be a lot of hair
twirling this game that's for sure oh
yeah and and you were
right eric your theory i think when
nervous moments or when you get low on
time the hair twirling yes the velocity
increases it really does that's uh
something i've never tried
i wonder i wonder how it happens
so where does david move his 95 probably
that looks like the most natural move is
he thinking about taking on b7 and
playing rook c7
but then knight a5
and then rook b8
bishop d2
yeah i see what you're trying to do
i think that's going to happen rook b8
rook b the b4 bishop d2 try to be a bit
annoying yeah this
a little something something i don't
know black only needs a draw so
should i say it can't just you know take
his foot off the gas pedal here
i always like watching these games
because yeah the players play well in
bad positions they are resourceful they
they're they're finding uh making it as
hard as possible for for the player in
the driver's seat to convert and that's
always uh
something that can be worked on and
learned from
should be five back in grishock land so
yeah okay
not much has changed
the grisha gets 342.
um
but alexi can barely move
no it does look comfortable for black
you you do get
a bit of an initiative or some uh you
get to look at fun lines where you're
attacking or sacking and getting getting
through for free i mean not for free the
kings on d8 but outside of the king
being on d8 everything's like protected
and compact
so one such fun line knight f4 rook c6
knight g6 and 94 intermezzo you can
resign
destruction on a grand scale
yeah look at this bishop on f1 and rook
on each one sitting there
you can't play like this you cannot play
without
your king's side
but you can develop your king it's like
catch 22. if you move your knight you
leave the other knight undefended if you
don't then your pieces are buried
so you're damned if you do damn if you
don't
now lexie can't find a move here he's
just but there is a move so can we find
the move daniel
okay i have an idea king d1 and knight
c1
how do you like that i actually don't
mind it i was gonna actually say queen
g5 i think the idea is actually to play
f3
and you don't want to hang e3
uh yeah
i think that yeah so
that's a good move i agree so if if rook
c6 now then we play your king d1
or f3 and then king d1
but then rook c6 is a little more
misplaced
right but if you go c6 then your rook
doesn't swing so now now f3 and maybe
king
d1 yeah to cover the f3 of course to
cover the e4 score because 94 is a huge
we could go king d1 right away because
of the pins so it's up to you
but i i think a combination of three and
king d1 here and we might be shuffling
back to the king's side
now before we know it it might land on
g1 i mean that is pretty clear i think
it's not a bad
idea
by sarana you might have to worry about
knight b6 knight c4 so i'm gravitating
towards king d1 first so that i can meet
knight p6 with knight f4 right away as
opposed to yes then he's done it his
knight b6 knight c4 looks a little scary
in a couple of lines
now knight b6 you play knight f4
right and all of a sudden
you know black's king side is
queen g5 is annoying once you get f3 you
can you can play king e1 king f2 d5 is
loose g6 is loose and all of a sudden
white's king is looking a bit safer so
uh i think serrano found a critical line
to get out of dodge
the one thing is if black's king were to
be on c8 the landscape of the position
would change completely because
you would have the additional resource
of rook takes c3 and 94 in many
positions
so alexi's still on very thin ice here
anything could happen
well what i'm worried about is
okay he's he's trying to be tricky he's
trying to strap the queen in something
three king e1 knight c4 knight c1
oh
my god because he's only weakening the
c4 square he's only weakening the c4
square right now knight c1 is a
is an all-star move
and that doesn't trap the queen but it
forces it back and
white is
finally enjoying his life here for the
first time in the game yeah you can
always play knight c1 because knight can
always go back to e2 and then to f4 so
it's a temporary temporary maneuver and
if it does the job of kicking away
black's queen from dangerous squares
then that's well worth it you don't have
to worry about checkmate anymore okay
i'll i'll move my knight back for the
sake of that
i like queen a5 i'm thinking grishok's
looking to sack the exchange
if you let white stabilize here i think
white is all of a sudden in a clear
driver's seat with f3 king e1 king f2 so
i'm strongly
looking at the exchange sack not because
it leads to checkmate
but just um
no but the clock the clock
it's dwindling and there's no increment
in king c8
finally pulls this king out of the pin
but it's too late isn't it it's not like
king see it is great and white's
unraveling this is
sorry blacks yeah white's coming out of
the position and uh
takes in king e2 this is close to losing
this is close to losing right now
you can just trade you can bring your
king to g6 is weak the rook on eight has
a problem collapses and all of a sudden
it's blacks whose queen side is
undefended was white whose king's side
was dead
now everything is coordinated
he's up on time
alexi just
pulled a rabbit out of the hat that was
incredibly impressive 94 by the way
there's even
seven oh i like queenie seven that's
night oh that's nice
d6 grisha
trying to get his king to b7 get his
rook into the game
um
you might be able to just
take on g6 here if you
want to be really principal but f3 and
king f2
and you just have a
killer end game better save one by the
way
wait fide save was supposed to win right
yes yes
he won we're yeah
heartbreaking blunder for baravian so
this game is all that remains
who will be
the final four is a bit of an idea
yeah
whoa what a fearless move
knight g4 yields nothing due to king g3
queen on a4 needs to get into the game
uh dania can't be playing without it
wait wait wait wait we're trying to
chase the king
so he's counting on king g3 right
okay he's trying to set it up but it's
just oh then you wanted to do one too
slow exactly and i still want to do it i
still want to go knight g4 and rook
takes e3
no
king g1
oh
now
94 take stakes d5 maybe queen d6
queen d6 or something
it just seems like grishok is
floundering he's not
generating any
tactical chances here
no
and he let white stabilize when you have
the knight
what was it
knight h7 and queen g3
but he's not he's he's playing the
stable moves queen g3 is now a threat
and g5 is in the mix as well so he's
he's kind of oh
g5 g5 and fighting on f4
wait it looks like rook is hanging on
the rook is hanging
it's over
rook c2 and then queen f3 after rookie
seven
and uh we're going to see a resignation
yes we are
right when he's uh coming back out again
yeah that's actually a very easy blunder
make queen c7 making sure that the
queens get off the board
sasha is not to play another move
and alexis arana
huge kudos to him upset
tough last game
he keeps his composure
very difficult position and he turns
around and beats alexander grishok
yeah i think uh well deserved he made a
couple key moves in a in a challenging
middle game where he was facing like
mating threats and
just he was very common collected
throughout and it felt like he actually
just held himself together better than
grishoku he only just got low on time
but
was very inconsistent with his plans
with what he wanted to do
um
and serena seemed to just have that
vision and executed it from start to
finish i mean he played this opening for
a reason
uh knowing that you know it does get a
little dicey but he has faith in himself
that he can find the right moves and
maneuver very sharp positions and he's
going for the most critical lines
and uh yeah that paid off
it did indeed
alexis serrano is into the winners
bracket and that means
our eight
preliminary winners
are set our bracket for the next round
is set as well and we will delve right
into those matches after a short break
we have hikara nakamura we have vladimir
feresay of duba and others napomnishi
they will all be duking it out in the
first stage of the winners bracket when
we come back here at the rapid chest
championship finals presented by
coinbase be back in a few
[Music]
so
a unique online event with enticing high
stakes the inaugural season of the rapid
chess championship delivered its fair
share of big names and big moments andy
karunakamura is going to win how did he
do that
with more than 50 grand masters claiming
cash prizes over six months of weekly
competition it was also home to a
healthy helping of big surprises e6
wandering up seven this has been such a
roller coaster awarding over half a
million dollars in cash money
but year one of the rcc is not done yet
the rapid chess championship is
presented by coinbase and the finals are
finally here
the brightest stars from the regular
season including hikaru nakamura fabiano
caruana alexander grisham and more are
back to take a run at a fresh 150 000
and the very first rapid chess
championship title
also in the mix the familiar faces of
top players known for dominating elite
online chess events
how will they handle the pressure of
chasing a championship
and crashing this party as wild card
invites some of the most famous names in
competitive chess drop in to stake their
claim to the thirty thousand dollar
first prize
my friends
it's the inaugural rapid chess
championship final
who will make history as our first rcc
champion
what surprises are still to come
we are soon to find out
back we are at the rapid chest
championship presented by coinbase this
is the first day of the four day
finals weekend and
we have our winners from round one set
they are about to begin the quarter
finals let's take a look
at our bracket eric no
huge upsets wesley defeating jaspin
hicaro defeating parham
but for the players who won it was
anything but an easy ride
definitely i mean uh there's a few
different story lines there it's the
minor upsets
uh i think
i know happened in the previous one but
jeffrey
jeffrey being ding is an upset and the
way it happened was
was uh
was remarkable i mean uh the disconnect
and armageddon so
but everybody deserving winners all
around um some people had a much
smoother
road and i'm curious if that actually is
a good thing or a bad thing because
getting an army getting out of the way
getting maybe even a loss out of the way
that can be helpful if you're still in
it and you you've already had that
experience
i do imagine you're more warmed up and
okay a match might take up to an hour
it's not like it's three hours or four
hours where you might be tired the
players should just be
finding their form now
you know it does not matter
it's only been an hour playing where
some of some of some of the guys who
went through an armageddon i think they
might uh
might be uh better prepared for this
for sure and uh we want to remind you
that there are 16 total players 12 from
the grand prix plant leaderboard and
four wild cards it is a double
elimination bracket so the players who
you just saw lose people like parham
they still have a chance if they win out
in the losers bracket because at the
very end
the winner of the winner's bracket and
the winner of the loser bracket face off
in the grand final
for
a first place prize of
thirty thousand
thirty thousand dollars it's such a big
number i can't can't say it
and uh handsome prizes all around even
the minimum prize five thousand dollars
that can buy you a lot the schedule's
very straightforward today is the
winners of the initial round and we're
about to see the quarterfinals tomorrow
saturday sunday the finals continue mark
your calendars the start time is exactly
the same
every day
okay the stage is set for the
quarterfinals the games will go on
simultaneously as
they already have and we will toggle
between them
it's going to be exciting
yep um
any predictions
any predictions well
i'm really excited about this jeffrey
wesley match i mean
i'm gonna yes i'm dodging your question
because i have a good record right now
you know one and a half yeah i'm trying
to get you i don't want to sully my
record
yeah
i'm gonna predict i'm gonna make a bold
prediction i think jeffrey's gonna win
this match
i feel like he was gonna be emboldened
by
the dag match and it just wesley
had
some signs of weakness i think i agree i
think wesley was a bit shaky
uh in both games of his match against uh
joshua
so uh i i kind of agree with you there
that uh there's
you know there might be some smart money
going on on jeffrey here to score an
upset um
but wesley's been here before he's
extremely experienced so
maybe he can just shake off uh the first
first round i mean he did win 2-0 but
shake it off and uh
he'll he'll find his form for the second
one
because yeah it was a little shaky
well wesley's reputation precedes him
let's take a quick look at his uh hired
player resume
his um
his tournament resume is absolutely
incredible
he's the reigning fisher random world
champion three-time us champion
apparently he makes the chessboard
chess.com board as small as possible so
he can play faster
i had never heard of that until
pretty recently but apparently a lot of
people do that we will see if it pays
pays off in the rcc do you do that no
you don't do that because you so
obviously
i i generally don't so we don't but i'm
in my office and i have like a 34 inch
monitor
so i don't put it on maximum i don't
make it really small but i don't put on
a maximum i don't have to
because it's like so much work to to
drag everything around on these like
huge monitors
so i totally get why people do it but i
don't do it like on a laptop or on a
normal screen so much but i totally get
why and for slow people like me it can
be a little helpful but i saw like a
photo of wesley a few years ago he had a
huge screen
and the board was like a tiny part of it
so like
yeah he takes it he takes it to a level
i understand not going like full screen
uh and shrinking a little bit but yeah
because if you're streaming yeah you you
have to be consistent and
i can't really uh play around with it so
much
so what do we make of this preparation
by jeffrey he's got over 10 minutes the
big question in this scotch what happens
if black takes on e5 what
what horrible things befall
black's position if he grabs the central
pawn
i guess rookie one
oh and maybe d6
there's some sort of c5 tactics
i mean why can also take c6
there could be c5 there could be taking
c6 maybe taking on c6 and then like
yeah i'm guessing taking on c6 i this is
probably all preparation i think the
scotch is like
you know it's it's a bit more of a
common choice than rapid if your
opponent doesn't have enough time to
remember theory they can fall into
trouble if they do remember okay you're
probably not gonna get anything but i
understand the try there's some forcing
variations and
uh he's gonna check uh wesley's uh
preparation
in these
open positions rook aba is full of venom
because what could happen here and i've
seen a lot of scotch games go down like
this
uh you know these sacrifices on c4
are pretty thematic like if white moves
the knight away from d2 black can snap
on c4 and then sack on b2
and the queen bishop battery is
absolutely deadly so jeffrey keeps his
knight on d2
and embarks on
another very thematic idea the h pawn
storm
looks pretty good to me
it does i mean i'm i'm are there some
net a4 ideas here are there some
like knight a4 right now
wow curious
no that looks great
so if you take
you gave the ideas
bang
bang and then there's a mate coming on
b2 though this is over
what is does white of a move here
because if you move the bishop back
obviously
yeah this is totally out of the question
oh bishop d4 i think is the move
so c5 then bishop a1 yeah yeah and if
you take the taking loses to 0k1 and you
lose the knight
and if c5 then you drop the bishop back
indeed
you know with bishop d4
um
[Music]
maybe it continues knight c5 or taking
on e5 i don't know it gets sharp um
[Music]
wesley might not want to go for some of
these lines because he's assuming hey
jeffrey's prepared this probably doesn't
work blah blah blah
we'll see how comfortable but based on
the clock situation already
based on the clock situation uh
jeffrey's still in his prep
and this is exactly what you want if
you're jeffrey you want to drag wesley
into early time pressure
because that's the only spot where he's
shown signs of weakness consistently is
when he's got you know when you're in a
time scramble that's jeffrey's best
chance so excellent preparation for
jeffrey and
we'll see if wesley can navigate the
twists and turns in this position
without having seen it before
not easy to out prepare wesley let me
put it that way
no
okay so he makes the practical choice
bring the knight back maybe put it to e6
and prepare to play d6 or c5 and
you want to get access to that king on
c2 it's it's easier said than done but
um if you don't do that then you have to
take on e5 there's two options try to
just bust open the queen side
or
target the c5 pawn
right
and
he's going back to c5 as you prescribed
as you prescribed
and uh let's take a look at the other
game we've got two games at a time
here in the quarterfinals and the other
game is
nepo against uh duba rather with the
white pieces against yana pomnishi
another catalan what's with the catalan
it's like
it's like the new berlin everybody's
playing it
i noticed that uh
yeah i mean i lost to it uh against
anish everyone's playing playing it
i don't know
i guess it's just how trend trends work
but white's getting uh
getting uh
some playable positions or dynamic
positions maybe some
sacrificial positions which have some
practical value
like something
this position is so
duboff
yeah black is up a pawn but white has
all these nasty uh checks and stuff
right maybe queen c3
is being threatened right now i
i wouldn't want this against duboff but
there's a guy who can defend i can i can
calculate through it all
sian
somebody is
you know
he's just he meets he meets fire with
fire
oh he certainly does their styles are
similar but duba in these types of
positions as steady
as an oak
okay that
wasn't his last name basically means oak
in russian ah
so
that's hilarious hilarious fun yeah
very funny
queen e5 centralizing the queen
attacking e2
but he's going to be putting the queen
on h8 right
of course
after knight f3 no i think
there's no other square right there's
another square
beautiful
so we might see this might have a move
here and uh
is this
is this theory is this dubai's prep
i would not put it past him queen queen
d2 knight c6 maybe queen f4
something like this yeah but okay get
some pieces doesn't this look scary this
looks like
there's definitely compensation yeah i
mean jan survived game one against
fabiano carawana in a minus five
position when he wasn't castled so this
is like child's play to him yes this is
like he's warmed up i'm taking this
any day
and of course he's no he's down on the
clock
what's this uh
is the spirit of grishok possessing him
what is this and there it is good catch
by you queen i clean hate is on the
board
only move
yeah yeah now now now i want to bring my
queen on c2
towards the king but harass pieces
that's why queen d2
you know looks attractive maybe there's
something else maybe e4 right maybe just
e4 and try to blow open the king that's
another one actually daniel loves these
types of moves remember g
g5 in his last game against mexican he
loves to use his pawns
uh to clear the bushes like wielding a
machete that kind of thing yep and it's
on the board
i don't want to think about too many
chess players with machetes because uh
yeah sorry for the violet analogy no
they're just they're just going to be
very clumsy not not even violent yeah
just yeah i might end up in the wrong
machete in the wrong thing
queen takes e4 is
forced now 95 was a threat so nepo
deploying his bishop to c6 the evolver
not liking it
do you think it's something like queen
f4 or something more subtle than queen f
uh queen g4
yeah i think a lot of people would
automatically give this check but what
you really want is to
is to optimize the knight so by playing
queen f4 you're setting up the huge
threat of knight e5
i think queen f4 is highly unpleasant
for black this position looks
bad
it's just like too much
i wouldn't touch this with a 10-inch
pole for with black
especially against duboff a 10-inch pole
and a 10-foot pole 10 football oh my god
long day on
commentary
et cetera et cetera queen f4 is on the
board
and if you have to play bishop takes f3
that's a terrible
sign
because it's a huge concession
and again we have an opposite called
bishop position where you know the
attacker
uh greatly benefits from that
transformation
yeah but i'm thinking around 95 that was
no no
absolutely game over now you absolutely
have to do it can you get away with
queen takes b2 afterward i mean i know
the answer is no i guess what i'm asking
is why not
why why wouldn't you be able to you are
a greedy guy
so maybe do you think it's just like
knight f6 check and knight g4 or
something oh
that's a really cool idea actually but
defending and attacking look at that
so i guess after a knight g4 black has
knight f6 black has to play king king f8
and king e7
yeah you're gonna get your knight back
to e4 so it feels like there should be
uh compensation
like more than compensation i should say
but
whoa he played it immediately
queen b2 no knight f6 checks oh no
to avoid it
that makes sense
that's what you think he'll do the queen
b2 move made sense
oh
and he's going to take the rook he gives
up the queen but he gets a
a wagon load of material for it
what does he take on d1 with that's the
big question here
um
[Music]
well let's look at taking with the rook
first because then you can make the
argument that
you took with the bishop
to me seems very unintuitive because it
appears that the presence of more heavy
pieces should favor the attacker
but he believes that white cannot deploy
the rook easily
oh my god how many forks are being uh
by the way we have a photo of wesley
so's chess setup
that i was alluding to the optimal this
is what peak performance looks like
ladies and gentlemen okay this is making
me nauseous
performance i could not no this is the
photo i've seen i could not that's
that's too much wasted space let me at
least put like
no my brain
is throwing a blue screen of death when
i see that like how is that you know but
then you don't get distracted you're
just focused on
yeah the larger the screen or the port
size
i don't know maybe more opportunity to
get distracted i'm not sure maybe it's
opposite maybe i would open up more tabs
if i was not using most of my screen but
that's that's the chess setup so that's
that's uh peak performance
beautiful absolutely beautiful in the
meantime white did end up picking up the
knight on a5 but
nepo gets a consolation prize he
eliminates the b pawn which means he's
got to pass c pawn
and that pawn is rearing to go
god and jeffrey's position is really
interesting too ah
where do we go
stay on up to you here i like both yeah
but i'm going to stay here for a little
while just until the smoke clears i have
an idea
so start with rick b1
and then the goal is to sack on b2
if and only if
you can win that pawn
and ideally win it like without giving
black any moves because yeah no if you
can win the pawn and the bishop you're
good queen queen and uh queen versus two
rooks with that that the h pawn and the
open king i think is good but
takes a different approach he
halts the progress of the pawn for the
time being
i'm going to make a bold prediction and
say nepo wins this
do you think i'll go three for three
you're giving me good odds i'll i'll
take dubai winning this
okay
and
i see where you're coming from
what bothers me about the long-term
prospects here is that if white is not
able to generate play against black skin
maybe h4 h5 should be considered
it seems like eventually nepal will
coordinate and once this pawn reaches c3
it you know it's a three result game
agreed no i mean and i think with the
yeah
black's king is safe there's no material
on the board that can really harass the
king you could say you can push the
h-bond down the board it's a bit slow
and even then
you don't have anything on the dark
squares to add more uh fuel to the fire
i i i can see nepo taking over this game
pretty easily but
i gotta i gotta stick with dubob because
he can't win this kind of position he's
bread and butter he attacked he wants
some material
he's got to be able to to round up the
game to finish the game first uh with
the way he he he started it and that
means he needs to convert this even
though it's going to be tough
um so
time pressure creeping in but the
position has stabilized i propose a very
quick detour to the jeffree game and
then we can go back
because this game is also heating up
with wesley
seems to have the better placed pieces
he's got the very active rooks
white's king tucked away in the corner
no clue how to evaluate this position
wesley's king looks safe uh to me maybe
it isn't but it actually looks quite
safe no it is and i prefer then i prefer
black
yeah there's all sorts of shenanigans
going on
wesley offers a draw with jeffrey
declined
can you believe that
jeffrey
nerves of
steel is understating it yeah stronger
than steel
well the materials even he played this
opening to push wesley and he hasn't
pushed wesley enough yet like he needs
to see this out i mean he played this
opening he wanted to open things up he
wanted to get to the king
he doesn't want to admit defeat and
and grab the draw here the position is
not bad for him it's just unclear and i
like his decision i do think he needs to
bring it to wesley
but he should repeat
i don't see any alternatives
yeah
now wesley could sack the queen but he's
not going to do it because the knight
can land on f6 on demand
to cancel out the bishop
so
is a repetition in the cards here
or will jeffrey
jefferly do something crazy
jeffrey jean will play right df1 maybe
but rook df1 the queen can maneuver to
e3
yes
and it's probably not helping white at
all to commit all their rooks
to the queen which actually becomes more
centralized so i agree with you i think
uh objectively
go for the draw here
wesley's tempted and it's like that old
trick you know when
there's a perpetual and you don't want
to draw you wait until you have five
seconds and then make a move to tempt
your opponent into playing
you know what i'm talking about
something you can do
yes oh and it backfires but when it
works it's the best feeling ever oh
[Music]
whoa
whoa whoa whoa rook takes f4 does he
want rook takes b2 he does
and then what a position c3 rook takes
b3
with
mate threats
galore can you can you harass that
bishop can you go like uh
oh that is queen d5 rook takes b3 and
rook a3 mate
no you didn't oh bang bang bang
and i took offense to that when the draw
get got turned down like
okay you don't want to draw you don't
get one
uh-oh
jeffrey's in big trouble that is a nasty
variation and it's so hard to find the
move he's got a minute and a half
clock dwindling
what is the actual the threat is rook
takes p3 check right yes
okay so knight c3 rook takes b3
that just looks totally lost actually it
is yeah yeah it looks looks definitely
lost it looks awful
and then in some lines you can just take
the rook on f4 while you're right no
idea knight c3 rook takes b3 rook f3
what i do takes a three queen a2 then
rook takes c3 oh you don't i love this
you don't take the queen you take the
knight
with a totally devastating
discovering
50 seconds
jeffrey's not finding a move here knight
f6 check
doesn't do much on the count of king h8
oh and then rook d4
um but still it takes me three something
seems off here
oh man
that draw for looking real good right
now yeah knight chief is about
no this is this is um
oh
whoa what a liquidation jeffrey found
the best line
i think there's like a million ways to
lose that and this one you're down two
pawns but all of black's pawns are weak
including the a pawn so
there's still some holding chances you
just need to
contain
we need to go back to the to the other
game because
pandemonium is on the board these games
are awesome but amazing i'm just like
yeah we don't know what to turn into i i
there's imbalances right just imbalances
people going for wins sacking material
uh
so we got a king walk here is it good is
it bad
f5 king f4 bishop h65
create a god
no but then there's 5 right
oh then there's rook c check in the end
yeah yeah got it got it too many puns is
the point you don't just want to win
white's queen back you want to win it
back on your terms
rook d5 immediately is also a a tricky
move
to consider
king f7 trying to walk the king up to g6
and set up mate threats i like king of
seven because you all wanna you wanna
pass the decision back to your opponent
they're going to time their kings in the
open you don't want to make a forcing
move you want to make like a tricky
small improving move and he goes for
that first line
this is not going to cut it roxy a check
what's going to happen now how is your
bet going to somehow work itself out
blunder or rook i don't know
no this is winning but i can see why
nepo was tempted by this this doesn't
look like plus four
bishop h3 is a threat
don't scare me like that he's gonna pick
up the pawn
and then nepal plays f3 and he's got an
inkling of hope
that's true there's always chances when
you get the pun in f3 bishop on e2 and
you can go like bishop e3 but dubois
wants to play with no risk and that
might have just backfired i think napa
will hold the draw
yeah
the the split pawns is tough
but um the 10 seconds doesn't help
either
still trying to hold that end game
can you take on f2
yeah why not
and you can even give up one of your
bishops for the pawn either one
i think we're going to see that just
don't blunder your rook as white dubois
can still lose
careful
draw draw by repetition nepo saves it
and back we go to the jeffrey game
that's an impressive hold by nepo
it most certainly is crazy game as well
and jeffrey's about to go down here uh
yeah wesley in a winning technical
position
oh
absolute buzz saw
i wish wesley was in the candidates the
way his form right now is
out of this world
it's out of this world i mean the
consistency
the precision
in crazily complex positions
yeah i mean he just switched gears like
from offering a draw
to like a couple moves later sacking
your queen i mean it's like a just that
you're switching gears psychologically
like in your head like and playing that
all like perfectly um just shows like a
lot of range there that that makes him
so dangerous he can play anything
anywhere
and and play it at a
top top 10 top five level
no words and don't breathe because the
next game is already underway
and uh
all wesley needs of the white pieces is
a draw yes try to beat wesley south
black on demand oh my god
i wonder if there's anybody harder to
beat with black
no i mean maybe hikaru but
i mean
comparable comparably different that's
i don't even want to think about it
yeah what would you play and what do you
think about it imbalance things
well first of all jeffrey needs to make
sure he's back at the computer
the the thing i don't do is spot wesley
so a minute
that's that's what you don't do
he's uh maybe taking a bathroom break or
just thinking about what to play because
it's a dilemma what do you play against
wesley when you need to win on-demand
another gracious move wesley added time
back to jeffrey's clock he added added
until he had 10 minutes
so sweet
oh
some feel good moments today
absolutely what haven't we had we've had
wholesome moves we need opposite of the
board we need chaos we need drama
we've got to wait until the finals
until the final of the finals
i think a benko gambit is the order of
the day
there it is
the prophet
but
i mean it was either that or a benoni
and i
do know that
jeffrey has played the benco before but
thank you okay okay
i see what you did there i appreciate it
wesley knows everything doesn't he no
but yeah the the banco he he's
i mean just try to get an unexplored
position against wesley and that's tough
enough
okay but jeffrey might have succeeded
he's gotten wesley to think here
obviously white is better
he's trying to change up the move order
right
it should be seven first and then delay
d6 for a moment maybe go for i don't
know an e6 i'm
not exactly sure but
he needs an idea you need an idea
against wesley
yeah i mean there's a couple of lines
that contributed to the benko
declining in popularity at the top level
and this is one of them putting the pawn
on e3 like this
didn't used to be popular before the
computer age but now
computers just
insist that black has insufficient
compensation
you know
you can bang your head against the wall
but white's just better
but there's tension you know jeffrey
forcing wesley into some early decisions
well is this saying wesley spend
90 seconds like he's down to eight and a
half minutes that's a good sign for
jeffrey
because you want to know that your
opponent's not in familiar territory you
want to know your decision has at least
paid off in that sense that that you're
playing against wesley
the man and not wesley the man plus the
preparation
and i think he can be
feel a bit comfortable there
for sure and we saw like josslyn played
non-theoretical game two and it must
been giving it to wesley and actually uh
ended up getting something i mean
granted it was with white but still
managed to get something there so
yeah but the way he played it he might
as well have been black like he didn't
really squeeze the most out of his first
move advantage
uh with h3 so what are the candidate
moves that wesley's agonizing over b
takes a6 is of course one of them
and the drawback if i understand this
correct is that it allows the knight a
first class ticket to
uh to b4 yes
so
that's the downside of that but if you
play a developing move
then black can force a very similar
scenario
with
a takes b5 and knight a6 knight b4
mm-hmm
so is there another scenario
e4 h3
e4 uh e6
h6 g5 no but i
i i'm not scared as white either but
jeffrey's gonna
mess things up on the board we know he
has to so
i can see why wesley doesn't necessarily
want
a chaotic position like that he finally
makes a move bishop c4
because i'm getting the feeling yeah
tabasco sauce he's yes
he he's more of an e6 style than this
slow d6 knight bd7 bingo he's he's going
for e6 he's going for maybe like some
sort of d5 potential so
a bit a bit of a different take on the
binko than a lot of the standard
positions that arise
what is uh palpatine
what's sorry i was not sure the greatest
pun of all time and you're interrupting
by analyzing the game no no no that's
why i realized it right away sorry sorry
what does pal uh order at the japanese
restaurant
all right
now to the less important things what
were you saying
no no i'm i'm distracted now i i
no comment for me
thinking about the benko box
right it's
so
so witty now generally if black can get
an isolated pawn on t5
that's a pretty good sign i i don't
dislike jeffrey's position here d6
but of course this pawn is extremely
well defended that's why wesley put a
bishop on support he anticipated this
yeah white wants to play what h3 bishop
f4
b3 the usual moves
yeah
i think bishop uh
but jeffrey preparing nineteen four
that's why
every temple matters for black right now
you play move like d6 you might just be
too slow to get your like compensation
rook a3 looks looks correct looks looks
class
that's such a smooth move because it
takes the sting out of knight e4 because
94 will no longer threaten to take on e3
will enable white
to continue his development
so what do you do is back here
the ball is being passed back
and jeffrey passes the ball right back
to wesley plays
really the only
move of this kind that he has but when
wesley plays h3 for example jeffrey will
have to actually embark on something
there's uh there's some positions maybe
with a rook on a3 like i know it's a
standard move maybe
it gets a little misplaced if you end up
playing pawn to b3 as white and black's
bishop opens up maybe it's hard to get
the
rook back into the game
um
okay he went bishop a6
i guess he's just counting on this
long-term pressure on d5 being
worth something especially he wants
maybe the banco idea of starting the
queen from d8 to a8
so if you trade then queen a8 and and
what's the third defender for white
for this uh d5 pawn it's gonna be hard
to figure out there might be an ip5 or
something but
i get we i think we get what jeffrey's
doing and
i like it for an
attempt yeah this is as good as it i was
going to point out a knight b5 bishop
back to b7 but wesley
is in general more than happy to repeat
obviously
jeffrey will not repeat that loses the
match
he's got wesley down to five minutes
also and it's only 16 moves in
he's up he's up four minutes on the
clock that's
that's like being up a pawn
yep
so depending on who you're playing pawn
have fun but it's definitely uh
[Music]
significant
well we will see what he comes up with
uh
shall we take a quick peek at our second
game yes
we've got yon
with the white
says oh my god what a terrible position
for duboff
uh
he can't move
bishop e7
is
what forced almost right because bishop
c5 is bishop d8
bishop b4 there's probably something
else but this is like
usually you have this position and
black's up upon and white is still doing
sure black was up a fine i thought oh
it's a four on three on the king side
and then i realized no it's a four on
four even material and you have this
this is as bad as it gets open a file
bishop on g2 d file i mean look at this
hot on c4
no but this is
and this is extremely uncomfortable for
players like two bob that thrive with
activity tactics flow creativity here
he's just going to be sat on and he's
not going to have any
counter play at all
likes tactics but he's a very strong
tactician when he needs to be
this is this is depressing i know like
this is like
easy prediction like this is a loss and
it's going to be like a loss where nepal
was five minutes on the clock and do bob
has like 10 seconds right because nepo
feeds off of like when he's rolling when
he's feeling good like like kind of like
in the candidates he can just blow
through lead players
he just plays all the moves instantly
and in this this is a position that you
can
start really playing all the moves
instantly and putting your opponent just
in a real serious box
yeah this phrase is overused um by
overconfident chess players but this
position really does play itself
i mean the pawns are itching to be
pushed c5b4
i mean in the 50s they'd probably resign
this position yes
the adjournment
guys jump in and figure out all the
different ways to needle this look at
that instantly he played c5 in less than
a second yeah c5 b4
bishop arms
g2
complementary
and it's like a flat-out threat by the
way when you play dubob and you think
about what he's good at or you're
worried about how he can beat you
this is the just ideal ideal situation
to have dubov
on the back foot with zero counter play
most of your dangers are gone he's gonna
bring the king to e7 f6 rook d8 is he in
time
king e7 i think what uh wesley nepo is
cooking something up here
f4
no
rook
i thought i looked at the rook
before but that doesn't seem too
convincing
okay worse comes to worse you can always
play rook d1 if you want to prevent rook
d8
so okay we're expecting f6 because if
you play rook d8 immediately obviously
you cannot really afford to drop a pawn
in this position that's the last thing
you want yeah what's worse than this
position this position down a pawn
so f6 is going to happen
do you play f4 after uh f6
this is my idea
right my idea is to take uh f4
f4
rook d8 fe 5
fe 5 rook f1 so then you can meet rook
f6 with rook t6 with rook f7 check
absolutely gorgeous rook takes d6 and we
can pull up an analysis board here
just to illustrate this line
rook f7 check intermezzo king has to
move you take d6
and uh it's time to administer the last
rights but
nepo
he goes for the more mundane rook d1
i like that as well
yeah rook b8
what if black tries to get the bishop
out
i think you have to play f4 by the way
you need to create some targets somehow
like yes f4 king f2
you've got to target a7 or e5
or b7 yeah i guess those are the three
targets but
yeah i mean the way that you
spoil that you you fritter away your
advantage if you're white is if this
rook disappears from the word if black
can trade a pair of ropes
the lion's share of the advantage
evaporates unless you can win the b7
pawn for example
but dubois a5 trying to do something
you can also bishop takes b7 or d7 but
probably unnecessary so here are you
supposed to play rook back to a1 okay
you just keep pushing i mean that bishop
b7 is devastating oh yeah you got bishop
b7 okay so a4
bishop yeah you'll get something like
bishop b7 which should be seven rook d7
king e56 and probably here
g4
maybe yeah might as well throw that in
why not
no that was very what's
what's the blunder here oh rookie seven
no we're not very good there yeah
no
okay all of this has happened but he did
not blunder for whatever reason oh wait
or did he
huh
he played e4 instantly
duboff plays rookie seven and the crazy
thing eric is if you have a rook trade
nepal king can pick up the pawns
b6
a2
now you don't have time for b7 and rook
a1 king d7 and
this is a draw
holy smokes
yeah so white needs a better version of
that where the pawns maybe are a little
bit better so i was looking at like rook
b6 check worst case and then
king f7 then
c6 so then fa2 you go rook it won and
he goes right here
you want to be left with the b pawn not
the c pawn
as an outsider if you end up being in a
pawn up end game so that black's king
has to travel you know further away
so i think i think he wants to make sure
he's left with the b-pawn and
um that's what i'm thinking c6 c6 and
like okay now there's ideas obviously
like rook a6 is being threatened right
now to win the game on the spot
so rook a7 right is
almost forced unless there's like a rook
a5 or something
and there is and he plays it but
apparently it loses even faster so c6 is
going to happen
c6
yeah did that just end it the thing is
the kingman f7 is poorly placed here in
terms of like stopping it so so c c6
okay well c6 let's continue
um
okay c6 rook c7
i think rugby
oh rook
v8
yeah maybe rook b8 i mean this doesn't
hurt
no because you can't move the camera
let's say king g6 i'll just go king g6
for the sake of it and amazingly white
could even just king f1 king e2 king c4
it just black is paralyzed there's no
other progress to be made yeah
yep
so this is a good line black's king is
not involved the king's not involved the
two rooks can't really deal with the two
connected passers
so
maybe duboff could have defended more
resiliently but this is not the kind of
game that you really can save
yeah and you can't be taking
e6 maybe is the last ditch attempt
now rick c7 is on the board
you don't even need rook beat you can
play king f1 straight away i just think
it's a good idea to immobilize the rook
even further
well rook be it stops king e6 because
then you have b6 rook c6 b7 with ricky
yeah so so i do i do like rook b8 i
actually
the other king six you might you might
as well bring your king in as you're
blocking yeah you have nothing to lose i
mean possession is already totally
hopeless
and he plays it and rook v8 instantly
follows
no this is this is not going to go his
way
i think wesley's also in trouble we
should switch to that game at some point
wesley's in trouble i think so all right
we can trust nepo to convert this this
is this game is over
and we have the following position
with jeffrey all over him he's won the
pawn
back well when you win the pawn in the
banco especially the c pawn then then
you're usually very happy
a4 is losing
but this is you know
you don't see wesley in positions like
this very often where it's just like
lacks coordination
and just has like pieces sticking out
like sore thumbs just hanging pieces
i'll tell you what if wes if what if
jeffrey wins on demand with black that
is like so impressive honestly like i
he's like immediately like
won the day or something for the gesture
with ding
and then just like the clutch win if you
were to do that like i'd have to give
him the mvp of the day almost no matter
what happens
no it would be unbelievable but the
game is obviously still yeah still going
and i think
the hope for white is that he can
stabilize the situation he can avoid the
immediate tactics
also to be noted is the back rank
uh this is a common situation where the
luft square is occupied by that darned
bishop
yes
um not a fire uh
this is a fire risk bishop on h2
yeah it's blocking the fire escape right
in case of elevator failure yeah the
stairs are blocked by the bishop
and whoa rook d5 bishop c3
and case in point like
if you play rook takes d6 i think
ooh
no bishop e5 doesn't work is the queen
when it takes on c4 can block a check
with queen f1 can you believe that
i can now
but rugby two i think is
looks pretty devastating what do you
want to do
queen d1
queen d1 i'm trying to find the wind and
it's hard to see i mean maybe it's there
you're allowing
can i go rook d8 and trade off and queen
back to d1 or no there have been it
feels good for blacks but i'm sure
there's a move i'll let you find it okay
this is on the board
and jeffrey up upon now in the end game
this looks like only a couple of
yeah yeah
i don't think that a pawn is gonna push
i mean yeah best case scenario you push
your pawn all the way to a7 and your
bishop on h2 swings all the way to b8 to
lock in that pawn
that's not happening rook a6 shuts the
door defends d6
and jeffrey has extremely good technique
so
right now i think he's looking at his
king on g and he's like i want my king
on d5 i want to bring my king in support
the pawns
bring all the pieces in and start
pushing
andy's up on time which is
the the cherry on top wesley below a
minute and we know that he's
he's been a little bit
flustered in time pressure
as good of a defender as he is
this looks like jeffrey is
just within a couple of steps
this bishop on d4 is worth with at least
the rook
yes it is just holding the whole
position
together maybe wesley regretting giving
jeffrey those extra extra 45 seconds at
the start
he's like wait wait can i have those
back actually
i forgot that i uh
you know so look before i like i love
them
shuts off another file and i do want to
play f5 and king f7 and king e6 and king
d5 i don't know why
want to bring the king in
otherwise you can probably push without
it but it feels like the king could be a
useful participant
i've seen people do that in the end game
sometimes bringing the king in yeah
relatively new idea
but bishop e3 what's uh wesley's gonna
try to play bishop e3 right now right
this i thought was winning but it's
actually logistically it's it's not that
great because
even rook after he defends the bishop
and opens up the attack on d6 what you
do not want to do with black correct me
if i'm wrong
is trade the a pawn for the d-pawn for
example unless you can ensure that
you're doubling on the second ring for
example yes
and it's official i see here that uh
netbo
has advanced
nebo has won
h6 trying to set up some mate threats
and maybe now is the best time for f5
it is
it is a good time for f5 and king f7
yeah because otherwise
i think that's what jeffrey's deciding
between i think he knows he's moving the
f pawn trying to figure out where to put
it you know f6 sometimes you can play g5
and trap drop the bishop not necessarily
there but it's actually not too far away
f6 king f7 g5 and the bishop is almost
trapped
and then rogue b2 becomes totally
devastating because the bishop can't
come back to e3 in that case yeah
i think he's gonna have six i i think i
have six somehow is uh
takes away more squares
his own clock if i'm jeffrey i want to
maintain the time advantage i don't want
to get into 30 seconds like wesley
you have a pawn any other time don't
give away one of them you have easy
moves to play here not necessarily the
best moves but easy moves i have six as
a move you can play in two seconds
yeah gotta play a little bit quicker
yeah the big issue here
when you get down to a time scramble
there's always uncertainty bishop b3 is
an excellent move
and that's an excellent response though
or is it isn't there rook
a2 d4
uh-huh and rugby no
oh bishop d2 and rugby one oh my god
jeffrey might have pinned himself
oh my lands eric do you see the problem
yes yes
deform fishing d2
rook has absolutely defended squares on
the b file and white goes rook b1
oh my god you're right you're you're
winning an exchange there
and that means jeffrey
has to go here but this is now
very close to a draw rook c1 so rooksy
won rook b three three
kingy two no rogue b2 check
i think
wesley has to find the best i think he
should keep all of the rooks on the
board
so he should take on c3 and then put the
other rook on c2 rogue d1 because you've
got this counter play based on black's
king business yeah yeah the seventh rank
sixth rank
use those yeah this should be a draw now
jeffrey's lower on time so now five rook
d6 rook d6 and rook c6 or that yeah and
now rook c6 next move probably right to
cut off the king or rook or even rook c7
check and just go after them
yeah
jeffrey trying to shoehorn white's king
onto an awkward spot
but it might go to the center
king d2 or king d3
can go king f3 but then you risk getting
checkmated four seconds for wesley
one second for wesley one second oh man
here we go wesley just needs to
clinch this match is he going for a king
walk
in the pawn
he's going to put his pawn on h4 maybe
g5 maybe g5 i was thinking the same
exact thing rook c7 check
no
king e2 he's going to win the pawn back
king f3 wesley's making progress here i
mean jeffrey jeffrey
really needs to find a move that's it
he's gonna take c5 oh king g2 why is he
take e7 takes e5 it's a draw
unless his internet fails unless he
blunders a rook oh that was a dangerous
free move but okay yes yes it was
and jeffrey graciously
admitting defeat with a draw
holy smokes what a game
what an effort by jeffrey didn't pan out
but man oh man did he die trying
no wesley had to find some tough moves
at the end he found the right move at
the right moment that was the only
chance i think the last little bit
where we actually saw a position that
was playable for white it was looking
awful and as soon as he had the one
moment
he took it even though he only had 20
seconds he saw it and
the precision needed to put away guys
like wesley is is high and
jeffrey was pretty much there today i
mean that was an awesome effort
with black
but
maybe the you know the the loss of
dwight in
in the first game is haunting him the
draw offer
yes
an incredible first two games of the
quarterfinals and the best news is that
we have two more games to play and they
will include hikaru nakamura so
whatever plans you have for the
afternoon cancel them you will not want
to miss
the other two quarter-final matches to
determine who stays in the winner's
bracket and who has to climb
wow incredible day so far you're
watching the rapid chess championship
finals presented by coinus and we will
be back with the rest of the
quarterfinals in just a couple short
moments
[Music]
so
welcome back to the rapid chess
championship presented by coinbase now
we spent a good part of the break trying
to decipher
uh a particular view
of wesley sews uh rcc setup and
we're just going to bring this to you
without comment
i'm
getting neural
overload circuit short circuiting
it
the chair is not where it should be
wesley's not sitting on the chair
the computer is sitting on the chair
he's hunched over
i mean how many things
are weird about this photo i cannot play
chess hunched over on my knees i cannot
be like crouching on a laptop like i i
don't even know how it's possible that
that's like i've never seen that before
and i thought i've seen
i've seen a lot of things in chess
you've seen you've seen all sorts of
stuff but not
is
it's working right but like that means
he's comfortable like that i i just
would be so uncomfortable
i i mean
he's on a carpet as well right like
just a carpet not like a
a fluffy carpet
right so i mean my knees would be
hurting i'd be like super hyper
and even the posture i mean
chess players aren't known for having
good posture
and i can't say that's
helping
helping you because
it's all the gaming chair companies
maybe around the world are like hey why
aren't they using the gaming chairs why
are they on the floor
i know it's it's nuts but uh in addition
to all the gaming chairs i hope the
software engineers in the chat are
paying attention because if you're tired
of getting random calls and texts with
bad job matches hired connects you to
over 10 000 employers worldwide through
one easy dashboard no cover letters or
applications just upfront salary data
and dedicated candidate experience
managers to support your incoming offers
take control of your career with hired
and we have a interesting question the
answer to which will be revealed
tomorrow once again software engineers
in the chat what do software engineers
unhired say is their least favorite
programming language is it objective c
is it kotlin is it java or is it c plus
plus
objective c kotlin java c plus the
answer will be revealed tomorrow but
feel free to discuss in the chat
we thank hired for sponsoring
the rcc and we hope the software
engineers in the chat have something to
think about but we are about to think
about the two other quarterfinal games
that are going to begin
and once again the x is on hikaru's back
eric he is the one that everybody's
trying to defeat
crushing parham in the first round well
everyone wants a defeat or even better
yet everyone wants someone else to
defeat him
someone take ikari out of the field then
everyone
you take your car out of the field and i
think a lot of the players think they
have a good chance of winning the event
right as long as he's in it he is the he
is the big favorite he's the big dog so
so you are you are looking at the
bracket you're hoping someone you got
people yeah everyone's everyone's
rooting for serrano right now that's for
sure
and i think alexi he's got a good skill
set in terms of playing a car he's
pretty calm
and he also plays fast which is
critically important because the last
thing you want against cecaro is
you know time pressure right out of the
opening
and he plays a very interesting opening
f6
you've never seen this in this specific
position
oh d4 queen a5 wins that wins the bishop
how do you like that
can you continue in that line
uh queen c3 bishop d2 queen b two a
but then it turns out that
this somehow is winning for white
in any case uh slightly different move
by nakamura and they've transitioned
almost into a benoni structure
with c4
i'm excited for this matchup
what does it look like it looks like a
reverse nimzo
indian f3 variation yes yes but
go on
so i was going to say we want to see car
against somebody new if like somebody
who's like not as like
afraid of yukaru or has a good style
surrounded prepares
for these matches he plays fast he's
practical
hikaru particularly does really well
against strong chess players that aren't
necessarily like seasoned online players
right like you know like like
particularly good at like the
the practical aspect of online chess
like he just feeds off of that
so i think i mean at least serana
he's a really really really good fighter
and uh you need to be able to frustrate
hikaru
that's one of the keys that not many
players can do that to last enough in
the game to
to actually be able to withstand some of
his pressure and make things hard and
like
not everyone can do that and and serena
i've seen when he's really playing well
and and he his nerves are very
impressive
so i'm hoping hoping we see uh
see some of that and get a good good
fight here
now an idea for white here would be to
play bishop a3 because if black castles
that's already a pretty big win
in terms of
king safety positionally black's got
domination over the center i mean black
owns the d4 square
white's center pieces are
discombobulated so
yukari needs to find a way to keep
the the fans flying
oh what's the phrase defend the flames
yeah the flames fanned there we go got
it
he has to keep the fans
the fans flames and the flames fanned
that's where i'm going to stop
and pass the mic to the fans go flames i
predicted the move at least
you did no you're right he has to be
very active to compensate for for this
but look at sarana's body language
he's got a hand like he looks very calm
and he looks like he's in familiar
territory
right i mean i personally wouldn't be so
calm with black because you can't castle
that's
that's clear because the bishop takes c6
and you drop the exchange it's not the
worst exchange in the world but you
definitely drop it so he's not gonna do
it but like i'm looking in that
direction
i'm looking that direction that you
maybe can
like look at how weak
d3 is look at how weak d4 is
there's going to be positions soon that
black might even be able to stack the
exchange for significant compensation on
the light squares or in the center
it's not now
just now because you'll be sucking
something a little bit more valuable
than the exchange or you're gonna get
checkmated by hikaru something
something's got to give here
there's
uh got a vehicular plan attack open up
use the bishops keep the king in the
middle black
get the king to safety get the queens
off
yeah queen g4 came to mind as a way to
offer a queen trade also attack g2
take six knight e4 is that the scary one
or is there something else yeah no
that's among the
among the scary options but not the only
one i think queen b3
queen takes g2 i mean
queen jesus yeah
you die with a full stomach
i would take on g2 or even play uh b5
there
oh yeah that is
a valid point
yeah you got all this decision for all
that's a good question by the way for
the software engineers i'm looking in
the chat we got a lot of people still
still arguing and commentating there's a
lot of software engineers
that's awesome they're
fighting over the language it's an
interesting question we will reveal the
answer tomorrow
and um
big decision for surrounding here where
do you put your queen or do you just
leave it there do you just leave your
queen on c4
just develop the bishop pretend nothing
is the matter bishop f5
yep bishop b4 is an option b
whoa
so the point of course is if knight
takes b5 there's an inter mezzo check on
e4 black wins
but what if bishop b3 does this not
send the bishop
essentially where it wants to go anyway
queen d3 then or should we go quinji
queen d feels like we want to go queen
each week because queen g4 still runs
into that 94 line what do you think
oh yeah quincy and now it's even worse
because the night what worries me is
that the knight on c6 is very loose
so once the knight moves away from c3
there's these additional problems with
that knight
yeah i think windy 3 is alexi's idea
and then
the ball is back in hikaru's court
in terms of because b4
thanks to you i now see that threat
well i like that we have like uh just a
fun position it's just gonna be like
someone's going down here carl's gonna
be left with a messy position
like an awful position
or he's just gonna
kill black's king he did play queen g4
so alexi sees something in that end game
which comes before bishop before knight
sorry queen g4 bishop g4 knight e4
what exactly is the threat maybe it's
just a general feeling of malaise
what were you thinking
no i was thinking bad moves but um no no
no so yeah i can't do that do you have
to go like b4 here or something
i believe is like he calculates well he
can handle these positions like yes like
what i mean is a position looks like oh
i shouldn't play that looks bad
he'll actually calculate it
carl blundered a piece or no
queen takes g2
the eval bar says minus seven is queen
takes g2 not just winning for black
yeah queen takes g2
oh my
god this is queen g2
king d7 okay but rook f1
no but then then you uh knight d5
knight d5 rook c6 bishop hd resigns
yeah
oh my god
if alexi finds queen takes you two he
wins the game
and he seems your car wouldn't resign
there he played queenie two so he'd
find a way to mate him in three moves
uh
he's gonna play queen g2 dania
oh my god the hikaru effect strikes
again
this is unbelievable
and now
we've got everything he got exactly what
he wanted
he would open the c file and he has his
knight on e3 which is an excellent
square covering g2 carbon g4 f5 i've
never seen anything like this in my life
i mean queen g2
zero one
yeah no it's losing
i mean but how do you how do you play
queen e4 check with the same idea when
you could take the pawn and thread and
checkmate at the same time how does that
make any luck he didn't have the idea to
take on g2 did he had the idea of just
forcing the knight to go back to e3 he
didn't even see the g2 bomb he's just
that is
it's black magic it's crazy
that that was that was just losing and
that was just
dead loss i and it's not hard to
calculate like no no actually not hard
to calculate plenty of time
and alexi is going to be furious at
himself after the game he's going to
realize that this is this was a chance
to
i don't know
he somehow like didn't see it or didn't
look for it or believe what hicary was
doing i don't i don't think he is a move
order thing i think it's very clear car
was putting his net on e3
um
i
i mean at the game is not over
but this is like when you get a chance
against hikaru i mean
you don't take it oh man hikaru
generally gives you zero chances when he
gives you one chance and you don't use
it you you forfeit the chance like this
you've got no chance you know how do you
expect to beat him
it's nuts
rook c4 i mean this just looks awful for
black now looks like white's got
everything he could possibly ask for
yep
there's still some so let's just say
queen g6
queen g6 and apparently hikaru saw it
immediately
it should be four
well can we go up queen d3 instead i
don't like queen g6 i take take it back
queen d3
it should be for anyone now i need to
find the move but at least my king
hopefully will survive so can i go
bishop e6 bishop e6 yes yes
yes bishop e6 but alex is going knight
d4
and the enemy he's a sharp player he is
a sharp player which is like
why we're surprised he missed queen g2
but he's still like
coming out hikaru here
yeah but this is not gonna work
i'm still in shock
i'm in i'm in absolute shock that he
missed queen takes g2
so d3
can be thrown in as an intermezzo to
send the queen back
and he does
black doesn't have enough firepower i
mean blackjack's got a fuel there's no
pieces to attack with
white's about to castle and then black
black is the one with their king stuck
in the middle of the board with nothing
uh to show for it so
um
d3 queen g6 you just take on before that
was the chance you play like like a
sharp opening like that where you have
to be very precise
you're precise you're doing well you're
not precise you're dead and i think
that's just the nature of these
positions that's why it was going to be
an exciting game regardless but
um
missed his chance and the nature of
trusting i think is that it happens
subconsciously it's not like alexi sees
queen g2 and says oh hikaru must have
seen it that occurs on a subconscious
level and basically prevents you from
taking these moves seriously against
anybody else
he'd play that in a heartbeat
yeah
no there's definitely yokaru effect
and that was a
picture-perfect illustration of it
and uh and i think we've been there
maybe not in a rapid game but in blitz
games for sure where you're looking at
the game afterward and it's like
how on earth could not could i not have
played this move you know and won the
game on the spot
should we check what should we stay oh
queen b7 we can we can jump to the other
game because it's it's really heating up
as well
this looks like it came from i don't
know a trigorin or something some
spanish line
but uh
that's exactly what it was
this is ray lopez written all over it in
like every way
yes interesting point hopefully serena
doesn't realize what he missed he
probably has it's better not to know
until afterwards because otherwise you
have you're just thinking about it like
you will not be able to play so
hopefully he hasn't recognized it but i
have a feeling he has
um
yeah and if he does then
i mean
i would not have the mental strength to
take the next game seriously
after an oversight like that
so what's happening here yeah
well intuitively it looks like abdu
sadharav is doing well just the bishop
pair and
the control like
you got this knight on c4 you got h3
loose you got g4 coming as a tactic
opening up the bishop on h6
it feels like the bishop pair should be
worth something maybe not like a crazy
amount but how do you stop the tactics
and he's very sharp very good at these
and look at the time three and a half
minutes
and counting
okay bishop takes c4 first of all g4 has
to be reckoned with right here
yes as an intermezzo
absolutely
and
motorbike might just say i'm not even
going to calculate this i'm just going
to make the move
let my opponent calculate it but g3
there is the move knight d2
bc
all right i'm done calculating this so
rook c4 bishop e5
g4 is all aboard 95.
whoa
i saw this i briefly
no
i
i thought
de is winning d e
d six rook c4 rook c4 works before and
then
your queen comes in or something
are you done
his idea might be to drop the bishop
back
well that's the concept and now d6 is a
threat and if you play bishop takes c1
why is it threat don't you have rook c4
but takes c1 first ah rook takes c1
first
what a genius concept by
the ever creative vladimir ferracev
okay so trade off the rooks on c2 after
bishop b3
trade off the rooks on c2 and then
it's on the board i think he might have
missed it
oh
dcn21 queen t1 or no what's the win
why not queen d1 why not queen the one
and queen d6 oh my lance
why that is that is it right queen d1
queen dc that's it bishop g5 queen d6
bishop d8
but there's got to be some move there
knight e3 or you take on e5
oh yeah
and then rushed it
oh my god what a move
this is some serious calculation this is
some like that's beautiful like you have
to work very hard just just uh just even
be looking there and see some of the
waiting moves like
d6 and then rook takes c1
that's some very deep calculation
of making an investment risking
because if this wouldn't have worked he
would have lost instantly he's got two
minutes left
and i'm just okay so after this
we don't need to take on e5
do we go knight e3 or knight g3 it feels
like we need to bring knight e3 makes
the most sense to prepare knight
d5 right but he's there to
then
okay so then we should so then we should
take on we should take on e5 e5
k7 so let's investigate here
here here
and then we bring the knight in maybe
and then if rook b7 queen d5
maybe yeah goodbye
no there's just way too many yeah
threats and avenues and white's also up
potentially two pawns
incredible i mean after what notre back
pulled off against gukesh
you know you can never relax against him
in rook b7 here there's queen takes b
and rook c7 so
bishop d8 is on the board
king h7 i'm looking for something
cleaner i for some reason
rook d2 exists
yeah it looks like there must be
something a little bit more
a little bit more i feel like we're
getting warmer rook d2 i'm i'm looking
at that i i
i want to buy what you're selling
seriously rook d2 it's a hard move again
to find
otherwise you could ready to queen see
it okay just take some oh
you know what what what's a very
fascinating mating pattern
or no queen see it actually spoils it
but if queen bee says
yes exactly i'm trying to go like this
god how many beautiful patterns have we
seen
today no today we've been spoiled with
the games uh dania i mean
this is fantastic we're seeing blow
after blow this game
uh fedoceve
solved a bad position with
some really really strong calculation
came out of left field it felt like
he had to create it all himself and
wasn't the setup from before it was more
of a reaction
you could by the way
orchestrate queen h2 and g5 in that move
order but bishop h3 there
you know black is hanging on by the skin
of his
you know
skin of his teeth
so do we do we take down go queen d5
take on c7 queen c7 queen d5 i'm
thinking of bishop g4 this queen g8 king
h6 queen f8 another mustang i actually
think he's going for g5
right now
yeah bishop h3 there's got to be some
sort of made maybe back up e5 and queen
yeah we're making serious progress there
like even if we don't find a win we're
up two pawns and our pawns are actually
good now they're mobile so bishop h3
queen e5 check king h7
then queen d5
queen g4 okay but you can always go
knight g3 yeah
yeah queen d5 i think ends the game
queen d5 ends the game
because if you move the bishop away
you have nowhere to move it if you play
bishop e7 you take c7 go queen g8 m8
queen d5
he simply takes
oh cause queen c7 he wants queen d5 and
black cannot defend g8 and protect the
bishop at the same time gr
god the calculation by vladimir has been
but this is
this is a super nice game
it really is the e7 queen f6
and
the worst thing is that queen g4 even
here is not a threat because of knight
g3
and white buys himself the tempo he
needs to deliver mate
so did you just play queen f7 and then
83 just to take away or even bishop f7
but i would play queen f7 queen g6
30 seconds though he's got to be careful
you never know
oh
no you i didn't i
still think
the king is stalemated black just gives
away all of his pieces
black plays queen g4 queen
and bishop takes g3
holy
cannoli
and watch him resign here
will he see
the king is stalemated it is still made
he's gonna find it he's a hundred
percent renegade renegade two minutes
that is beautiful
because you have to take all the pieces
otherwise you get made it yourself
otherwise you get mated you you have to
take one of the bishops
oh my god gives you a check on et you
have to take the other one and then i
mean easily it gives itself away
oh queenie two
this is incredible
this is one of the most amazing moments
we've seen
just a queenie two queen h2 queen takes
g3 is the simp
he missed it but he finds another
drawing mode
whoa he found a second drawing move
yeah so pontics you just have queen two
queen h52
bishop f7 was a howler of biblical
proportions
[Music]
he played an amazing middle game
absolutely stunning
and just one slip at the end
you're gonna have to show the stalemate
after because i'm not sure if everybody
absolutely but first we are going to
hikaru is messing up
that position queen d3
and alexis serrano is back from the dead
again
what what is going on today what have
these players eating for breakfast
i usually skip breakfast i do as well
but clearly these players haven't i
don't know what they had they didn't
have their coffee rook d7
no but surrounded just like ice ice cold
i felt worried about getting mated
just not worried at all
queen g and there's no way
queen g4 queen f3 but then whites up a
pawn but he's gonna that's forced right
or icaro has to be very careful not to
lose this if he goes for it
but queen g4
g6 maybe okay talk about ice cold
then queen f4
so you're gonna end up having to do it
anyways the problem with g6 is then your
king is even worse i guess right in some
of the end games if you end up ever
being down upon i don't know right but
here the rook is placed very very well
alexis should be able to hold this
every russian school boy
yep he studied
two years old i probably wouldn't but
i would lose this
honestly probably nine times out of ten
this is gonna bring the king to b3 and
he's hoping to get rook d4 check in so
what is he going to play g5 now or you
want to keep the integrity of your pawns
you want to make a move in one second
that's
it looks dodgy but i actually think it's
fine
because it's all about the pawns
he's got to buy himself a little bit
more time
he's losing now
no the rook just goes behind the pawn
and the car pushes
because he defends f2
but alexis is trying to give away
his rook for the i mean this is
but this is gonna be hard to win because
king h3 is coming oh and king e4 he
makes it in time
but
how do you win this
you're going to eventually be like rook
a3 or something you're going to be able
to cut the king off right
and the issue is that king g2 walks into
like f3 or f4 check
oh andy karu makes it in time the black
king does not make it to g2 in time to
give the rook away for the a7 pawn
hikaru wins again
yeah not an easy looking game to hold
still i i don't yeah yeah i i think that
practically it was never
lexie all right time to resign
and now when he discovers that he
misqueen takes g2
that will be some epic pain
oh my god we have a second game
we have a second game so serena needs to
win on demand with white we're in for uh
some exciting chess there and
fedo save and abduct that was like a 12
round
boxing draw and there's there's there's
going to be a perk too
eric look at alexi's camera he literally
just discovered it i was about to tell
you
yes we could see the moment when he ran
it through the engine
oh
and you can just
oh and now he's thinking about it yeah
no no now he's going through like the
five stages of grief or whatever just
like
it's done
but he's got one of which is denial like
no it didn't actually the the the
position did not this is a different
position
rook b1
wow what
what a strange looking move
but it's a good opening for a muslin
game
yeah
and
i like it
no i like it too what alexi has to try
to do is channel his anger
into
giving himself another chance
but will he be able not only to put
aside
all of the pain and negative emotions
but he also has to beat hikaru like it's
not enough to do that he also has to
actually win the game yeah
even in the best frame of mind
it's going to have an impossible task
i'm going to have to get into like some
sharp complicated miller game that you
can get a heat cargo uncomfortable
i mean nimzos is bread and better he
carries plays a lot
but
sometimes white can get a really strong
attack here
really fast and
i'm not sure that's gonna be one of one
of those instances but the imbalance is
there
by the way we will show the stalemate
but what i would propose i almost never
do this
but for a coinbase
uh
critical recap
um i'm pretty sure
choosing the feta save game would just
encapsulate the amazingness that we've
seen today
so worry not you will get to see the
stalemate again
um
but oh my lens
brief
and better saves game i think is heading
toward a quick draw
or is it
okay let's let's flip to it for a second
enlighten me is this
is notre breck playing for a win here uh
i'm gonna actually say not really
so i'm gonna say no i don't think he's
playing for a win based on this
so um
i think i think there's a very likely
draw in that game
he he might have an idea to do something
like
i can't give a full answer yet he might
have like something around here that he
wants to try but
i think the decision was a very calm
calculated one that he's okay he's gonna
try out a couple moves
um
if he gets nothing he'll know very early
on if he gets nothing that'll go to
armageddon
he's not he's not pushing hard that's
for sure but he's playing without risk
because basically he wants to
he's slightly better i mean there's no
question that if i had to choose a side
i would choose why it has slightly
better place to be as is usually the
case in this line of the berlin
yeah it's just so so explored and
generally the one where
yeah there's a lot of quick draws in
this line i don't necessarily think he's
going for that but
we're waiting for what white's idea is
gonna be in a couple of moves where okay
it's a symmetrical position you're a
little bit end development
but if you're heading development you
need to manifest you know you need to
convert that into something needs to be
tangible can you put pressure on on on a
square on a pawn
what is that going to look like for uh
i've just said around here because yeah
the pieces look good but you're done
you've developed
right now
one sign that it's been a long day i was
about to propose bishop c7
nc7 and queen eight checkmate yes but is
the rather subtle
idea that the
knight moving away from g7 has opened
that square up
so
let's strike that from the record no i
think this is just gonna cut yourself
out myself just in time he's thinking
now if he has an idea or not i i don't
think he has an idea
before he doesn't want to or he doesn't
want to use an idea
we'll see well 95 could be annoying i i
could see this getting a little annoying
for black feneste makes a sloppy move or
two
you're checking if your opponent makes a
sloppy move that's that's definitely
um
you know yeah that's what you're looking
for if they do
you push harder they don't
it's going to fizzle out
yeah bishop g4
and he's provoking the knight onto e5
he's saying come to papa you know
what is the
purpose does he want to drop back to e6
somehow
bishop b6 knight f5 this is too subtle
you know it is rapid so even though the
berlin's really solid and everything and
pretty drawish like
you don't have enough time to make all
the really good moves probably h3 i'm
guessing h3 is going to happen to tuck
the bishop in maybe knight e6 bishop h2
bishop g5
then queen f3
or that
maybe f4 can be considered although it's
a very committal move
so so yeah white white's got
white still has a little
there's a meat on the bottom as you
would say yes
a little advantage here okay some
squeeze maybe a little press yes
so
we'll see
no risk you know fun chess and joy is a
position
i love it i need more of that
so in the
hicarro game
the
uh structure has
solidified literally
it has ossified but now it's getting
reopened again
this is what you got to do is white so
uh i don't know the the eval the carbons
look normal but white's just looking up
bulldoze this position so that those
bishops on d3 and c1 can breathe can
attack
create chances and also get access to
that e6 square
um that could also be juicy
yeah that square is the bane of black's
existence in some of these positions
now alexi has done everything right from
a strategic standpoint
from a match strategy standpoint he's
done everything right he's given himself
chances but can he capitalize
the second time around
he's made hikaru
seemingly uncomfortable which is very
hard to do
knight f6
and the bishop has to drop back to c2
but you know if black doesn't get to
undermine the c4 pawn here and this kind
of
continues to play on the king's side
that favors white
because because if you're not actually
taking advantage of the the weakened
structure the diamond structure c3 c4 d5
then if all the the corridor is all on
the king side it does favor the bishops
because
your black is not white's not being
punished for the weak pawns if anything
the rounds are actually good because
they support d5 and the space in the
center
um
so i i i give a slight edge for white if
that maintains
i was about to say e4
is an interesting choice just sacking
the e4 pawn and then playing bishop f5
to get a good knight versus bad bishop
scenario that's a hikaru-esque decision
so it is a move like queen e8 for
example
or maybe even g6 well yeah because you
have to consider in that line
if white wants to play active they
should meet the eventual line with g4 f4
uh search
so that's what they're fighting over 94
94 bishop b4 bishop f5 like
yes black's gonna sack a pawn can white
continue to push those pawns through
right
but i would also be concerned about f5
the immediate definitely no i5 is an
automatic move
automatically f5 and this looks awful
so
that's what led me to
think of gc but as you're saying yeah
then g4 f5
there's a hulk on g6 that can be
torn down
no it's uncomfortable for black
there's some questions being asked right
now yukari might be able to answer them
but there's definitely some questions
being posed
where where white could get a very
strong initiative with the bishops in
the pawn uh
queen one
[Music]
because okay queen one then you got h3
coming
i like it
and i think that's the
the amazing the only way to preserve a
tenable position hikaru finds it or do
you just take the pawn did you just take
on e4 anyways
because again in that whole line
i like the pawn sacrifice practically
speaking
but at the same time white probably has
to entertain it anyways because
that's the situation if you don't take
the pawn ever if you think about the
long long run
you know plant planting into your 60s
you know
taking money out of your ira kind of
thing the d6 pawn could be a problem in
some end game
with the rook appearing on e6 or a
bishop on f4 so this doesn't this isn't
a panacea bishop f5 it just gives black
something
decently playable
but the chess players don't have savings
accounts
that's
didn't calculate the variation so to
speak
yeah maybe can't believe i used the word
ira in a chess commentary
all the bankers would be proud of me
charlotte is rubbing off on me that's
the roth
there's i think there is a type of ira
called a roth ira
yeah
which i
well unashamedly admit i have no idea
that's like a very adult thing to talk
about iris
um
we're still hopefully kind of young
so let's table that conversation my
identity 40th edition of rcc
yes we'll save it for the 40th edition
agreed
is there a knight h1 here
and i'm only joking so so uh do you play
h3n at h1
because i would play h3 because then you
can play f5 yeah so so h3
h3 what do they do they take on g3
bishop
oh i didn't see that because if bishop
f5 queen g5 and g4 was my idea
this is why this is danger zone alexi
could blunder this
yes
i mean h3 is forcing
and it's consistent with white's plan so
what does white do alexa not now
alexa not now hello alexa
did you ask something that alexa might
have been able to answer
hi alexa
no but i'm wearing headphones so she's
not hearing me alexa eric says hi
sorry i'm not sure
she talks up a storm and he missed it
no i i missed it too i dropped the same
soap
uh that's that's it knight g3
so how do we salvage it hikaru's gonna
he's a shark he's gonna see it right
away obviously
he's checking to see what it is he has
to play
or he's gonna get run over
that's the problem what's so terrible
about these types of blunders is that it
like your opponent can't miss it there
are certain blunders where
you have to find a difficult initial
move but then there's others where the
move stares you right in the face
and alexi i mean this is just such a
tragedy for him because
two games out of two he put himself in a
position for success
um
and stood in his own way and now yeah
like now it's just like no it's true
yeah the chances are
it's an understandable
blunder i mean i might have blundered it
but to beat hikaru again you got to kind
of play like
flawlessly or close to flawlessly or and
take all the chances and it's not good
enough that's why i'm not i'm not
playing
uh you can't afford any blunders and now
even if you win back material hikaru's
gonna make it in a way
that you can probably win back the pawn
but you'll have zero winning chances
like he'll just find a way to liquidate
that that just draws that takes away all
the winning chances deprives all
enjoyment you have in the game yeah you
don't beat hikaru from this kind of
position so
the time i think has come for us to
check in on the other game
which is proceeding
quite a bit more
smoothly and uneventfully
and i think an armageddon here might be
very much in the cards yeah i was saying
that i guess rookie 3 queen g3 knight f3
but i still don't know what you're doing
right people just like move around in
those positions and
pretend they have an advantage
but like
you might as well i guess torture your
opponent if you have white
yeah pretend that they have an advantage
a very good way of putting it the f4
square concerns me a little bit like if
you play queen g3
and black blaze 96 all of a sudden
you know maybe it's uh it's high time to
offer a draw then then knight f3
if queen f4 maybe g5
yeah i draw no no it's
black usually gets it
there's a famous story about uh richard
taikman one of the the top players of
the 19th century i think he was playing
tarash
and the story goes that he really wanted
to see an opera or a theater
and tarash was uh playing
playing out at dead drawn position so
tyman said he was known for these kinds
of antics he sweeps all the pieces off
the board and says
you know stop being foolish
um let's go see the play
drawn game
he's just he does not yeah super pieces
draw he just uh made a
i like that citizen's arrest kind of
thing you know that's you you got i mean
i would like to see a play or opera
yeah i think i'd be inclined to really
we're both really into opera
when in rome yeah no it's just trying to
just trying to expand that knowledge
base nothing like some
la traviata
i can't draw commentary references like
that
la traviata
yeah verdi
not that i've ever seen it i think i
might even i think i slept through it
oh
so
but now f6 and
no f6 and h5 drops g6 i'm trying to see
if black might be able to flirt with
a little some something in the end game
no flirting here
no
but now it's definitely yeah i said yeah
it's
well if you want to if you want to flirt
with black i guess you what you want to
play g5 and h5
pull around with the pawns on the king
side
did you say bumble or fumble i said
bumble around yeah yeah yeah yeah there
you go yeah you're but you don't want to
get too unhinged
okay
all right all right
points points for me for that
full points oh at least that was smooth
see
i like someone who can appreciate a good
pun
i don't catch all of them but i caught
those
no those were
those were all stars a4 again pretending
that white is pressing
yeah i think but a4 a5 bring the knight
to c3 no but it's yeah
i'm not going to predict who wins but
i'm going to predict that we're going to
have some adventures in this end game
there's different types of end games
this is obviously equal but it's not a
dead draw it's unbalanced enough to
where you can see
one side deciding to
get ambitious and
you know throw some tinder into the fire
that is what happens
we are gonna yep yep
it should be three
yeah i mean you you connected those all
like immediately i thought it would take
more time but that that's you you just
ran through almost like i've done it
before
ah
but not quite as smoothly
i appreciate it um
i'm going to favor white here and i've
like just always a smidgen but like
i mean i'll do saturated like
i don't know which rating they're using
i think he's over 2700 feet a live now
and the guys just got a world of
confidence uh in them so like there's
got to be some sort of feeling that he's
like i can just like kind of like i'll
play some of these uh some of my
contemporaries in in equal or slightly
equal positions
uh okay hicaro's about to checkmate his
opponent so let's switch briefly
to the hikaru game just to see the
finale if that's okay
i know the chat is itching
to catch serrano's last breaths
here not much to say
check check mate queen g1 rookie 3 queen
takes
g2 then queen h5
oh
that's not me yet it's not made it's not
mega okay okay i take the rook on d5
yeah rookie three queen g2 queen takes
d5 and queen f3
is the car gonna make a draw here
no
there's no way it's literally made
oh but by the way we didn't finish all
the yeah
we're gonna have to see someone uh
grind grind the end game down
yeah yeah no let's
but we got to see the conclusion of this
game
come on hikar you can do it rookie three
queen takes g2 and queen takes rook
really riley he's going for the draw i
mean he doesn't he wants to qualify i
guess that is the only important thing
professional one and a half
very professional okay back we go
last remaining game we just have to find
out who's the better grinder that jose
ever abdul sadarov
see i caught some of yours
too i think if white can get c4 c5 in i
would argue that white's advantage
becomes quite serious
no c4 knight takes b5
that's right that's the trick but you
know what like
that's always hovering over the position
but
like spawn structure wise you get your
king to f4 doesn't it feel like
white kind of has a bit of a
a pull here
or like
you go roxy too do you go do we go roxy
too so we actually here's what you do
you wait for king e7 and then you go c4
so that knight takes b5 meets with one
check
so now we should go king g3 yes walk on
the dark squares pretend that you're
just going to f4
i predict yep yep
white sweats gonna get a little
something there
yeah oh he blunted it
or did he no
what
what's going on here he's gonna take on
f5
then bishop takes out five boo but
that's a draw bishop f5 bishop h7 black
takes on d4
no he's not gonna he's gonna play king
e3 here right he's not gonna
bishop d3
b6
and we have draw yeah we have typical
draw position rook f1
and then d5
find some repetition yeah
yeah maybe white still has a tiny pool
with that protected passer on d5
but i i have a feeling we're going to
i know i agree with the getting
see who has the high ground going into
the armageddon
they want to see who is on the better
end of the draw that's where the two
players are jousting
yeah rookie 7 check king d3
[Music]
d6
96 then maybe bishop g6 check
and then maybe you got rookie three in
right where are you putting your bishop
here uh danya
oh there's a pawning okay but then you
take on c4 right bishop c4 wait but
bishop c4 knight c4 knight c4 rook c4 oh
oops
rooksy and richie
i gotta show that line really quickly
looks like you liquidate but bang
wham
bang and you have
trousers
and he sees it bishop eight he sees
everything but now he's upon down simply
uh
yeah
still might might not be losing it's not
the worst spawn but it's definitely not
a positive development so this is one
question
no then you lose your your structure
then there's like bishop e5
okay so so we play
we play
i'm i'm saying that until i find a move
and i'm not fighting a move i'm trying
to like we're gonna play the whole
problem bishop before ninety four ninety
four bishop yeah he plays him
so what was wrong with bishop before
ninety four to go rookie bishop g6 there
rook f1 check rook f4 a5 and i think he
was worried black would promote yeah
just just run the pawn down
this is a this is a three result game
with a draw being the most likely
now d5 and 94
is possible he brings the rook into the
game
so so if i'm white and i had a minute
i'm back at six seconds the knight's
gonna do damage here white has no times
he's gotta catch up on timer let black
you know get down on the clock because
that knight and that pass pawn will be
tricky objectively this is a draw but i
think it's very easy to blunder but you
do need to
hold on
keep the pawns keep the tension somehow
photo has to avoid getting down yeah
like you're absolutely right
after a5 the king is almost out of
squares but there's obvious there's no
mating that i think i established that
after e5 i can go king c5 right
and black has only created a hole
through which the king can squeeze in to
black side of the moon d5 and rock takes
d6 is a draw
but yeah
but that would last
rook d6
i'm trying to figure out if you can take
a knight there i think you can
rook d6 dc rook takes d2
and i think black actually stops the
pawn
it's armageddon time ladies and
gentlemen
yes rook d6 rook d6
that that is a very good find by fedor
sayev because otherwise he would have
had to suffer rook and knight versus
rook
and he was able yeah exactly he was able
and that's just unnecessary even though
it's a clear draw it's just unnecessary
here he was on even the good side of it
so that's
oh this is a good match these guys these
guys have been uh
real real really back and forth here
they are pretty
evenly matched and it's been
a wild ride with vladimir fetuses let's
not forget squandering that opportunity
in the first game i think now eric
if you don't mind is is a great chance
to show
that stalemate
and i would like to thank everybody for
patiently waiting we wanted to
catch all the action live
but now
we
let me pull that up real fast here
all right players settle in for the bill
joining us and uh a check uh still mid
idea to start the day
i think it's pretty sweet
so this is where the trouble started i
think and you might disagree with this
but the simplest win was to play queen
f7 queen takes g6
resigns queen g4 knight g3 you want the
queen h6 mate or queen g now the
hilarious thing here is that the king is
still stalemated but the difference is
that the bishop covers d1 so you can't
give everything away at the same time
but he played bishop f7 this gives the
queen the d1 square
and after queen d1 bishop takes you
three f63 there happened to be two draws
the first is what he did but the
stalemate was prettier queen e2
queen g2
and you back the king into a corner and
force it to take the queen
still
ain't that abute
the position speaks for itself doesn't
it
it does no that would have been that
would be really nice bishop f7 is one of
those moves you play and you immediately
play it you realize it's like i did
something wrong it's just like
why did i do that it's like i gave my
opponent a move that didn't need to be
give them give them a shot on goal
because there was two draws you know you
like there's two draws which is a lot
more than
than you you know i'm sure fedor uh
expected
yeah he expected
aggressively zero draws and he got two
and of course he saw queen d1 but just
short-circuited that
you know white's pieces abandoned their
monarch
and the knight is now yeah he missed
bishop f5 and he still made an idea but
it's one thing like we saw it it's
another thing for the players to play it
under like 10 seconds 20 seconds and
abu sadharav is there these both of
these players are super optim
opportunistic they they are whenever
somebody's uh giving them a chance that
they're reversing the positions we saw
that in game one
uh from both players and uh
yeah i mean uh
i'm really looking forward to this
armageddon
notre beck will have white
fetishes will have black with eight
minutes and 10 seconds
now for those of you
surprised that hikaru quonuko missed
made in five i'm sure he
saw the concept of the mate but like you
said very professional the result of the
game literally did not matter as long as
he drew a draw is
equivalent to a win
and he knew for a fact that he had
repetition so it's an understandable
decision
yep
you know
there's a
separate narrative in these tournaments
that you know if you if you're playing a
match you have to win the match and the
game is underway
and we have a rui lopez
what is happening here
this isn't a lopez right
i think it was it was a rulo because it
was an auntie berlin
holy smokes that looked like e7 in this
position
andrei can sometimes play this but not
in this move order
d4 e takes d4 a trade on f6
what the heck is this
c6 bishop c4 d5 grabbing the center
takes takes bishop b5 king f8 knight b2
queen v6 a4 this is currently on the
board
this uh resembles like a french
terrace
right there's some positions with the uh
double d pawns or something yeah and
you've got this bishop and queen
huh but should be two is fetishive
better here like knight b3
is coming to a theater theater near you
and if white can reclaim t4 i think
white is definitely better so notre back
has to be
pretty happy here with the outcome of
the opening
i think one thing to note is like yeah
the the structure for black is pretty
weak
and also white hasn't touched h2 g2 f2
so the g file
while black could use it to attack
white hasn't really weakened their king
so it's going to be a little harder to
even come up with some dynamic
compensation so i do like
feels
cozy for for white but
better say of
just taking the pawns and
and asking white to prove it
and what was the bid again uh dania
well nuterberg bid nine minutes fed us
at 8 10. so vladimir has spent two
minutes
so they're both talk about
opportunistic taking the two yeah they
are both cheapskates but that means that
means fedocere the entire day got the
best deal he got black with eight
plus on the clock and everyone else who
had black had less than eight
yeah he he just found a way you know
he weaseled his way to 10 minutes okay
knight b takes d4 so pawn count is
currently
five to six
but a save
evacuating the queen back to his side of
the board
but black's position still bothers me
it looks ugly it's hard to appreciate it
but the one thing is at least the pawns
they're taking away a lot of squares
it's not like it's that clear where the
knights are going to go i i like white's
position but
there's some there's some sturdiness
here where it's like you know what your
knights look nice your pieces look nice
but but where are they going to go how
are you going to get to e5 or f5 or g5 i
can get my queen to h5 as white i'll be
happy
but how am i going to get there how am i
going to do that get my pieces further
and i'll one-up you even if you get the
queen h5 what do you do after that i
think the underlying problem is the lack
of targets in black's position now you
might say what do you mean but f6 is
hard to get to d5 is nicely protected by
the knight so fedex can kind of just go
queen c7 and chill and and work on
his position bit by bit
white's not worse obviously but it's
hard to make progress
white that's right black initiated this
opening in this position which shows
that there's a level of comfort
or understanding that fedocide has with
this pawn structure i willingly went for
it
so that's different than someone oh my
palms got messed up i've never been here
this looks ugly right those feelings not
the same here he seems fairly
comfortable playing this with the bishop
pair and the dynamic compensation that
comes with it
but both these players they don't shy
away from from critical lines and fights
so
um we are going to see
norderbeck
try to get to that f6 pawn try to get to
the six spawn it's good it's going to
take some work
i think you want to get a knight to f5
knight f5 and you're gonna have to look
at exchange sacks
uh somewhere uh get rid of black's
knight on e7 or something he's he's
gonna look for something positional like
a long-term structural sack that that's
my prediction
but he's got to be very careful about a
potential bishop takes you through the
only reason that doesn't work well there
was knight h2 at the end of the line but
once again a draw is a win for black
great move by fedex
entrenching his bishop
on a nice square queen c1 king g7 what
about bishop d3 here
whoa he took it why did he take
that looks very off
took the pawns to the orthodontist
he's going to play f6 here you have to
play up six right queen c1 king g7 once
again no f6 is going to happen
that's a strange decision why didn't he
uh
he could have always grabbed on on e5 i
felt like i thought you could that
seemed like a last last ditch kind of
thing like oh i need to change the pawn
structure i'm making zero progress but
he was he was getting some stuff done
knight g6
also good
yeah but you don't like it
well i'm just trying to figure out why
f6 wasn't played because i like the 97
and how it you know defends d5 and
covers f5 and
provides shelter you can still play f6
f6 and king g7 so i'm okay with it
but i'm wondering why you chose this
move or there's a reason i'm just trying
to figure out what maybe he's
attracted to the potential idea of
sticking a knight on f4
why should white can go bishop f1 here
and then f6 uh the onus is on white
multiple ways yes you have to win with
armageddon but you're also down upon
and you have a poor pawn structure in
the queen side so
um
i think things are looking good for fedo
save right now
i think this was a very panicky decision
by notre beck to take
on e5 he he saw ghosts here and
now he's got to manufacture more counter
play out of nowhere
rook db1 threatening bishop takes a6 but
that's a prosaic threat king g7 defends
against that
i don't see
what his follow-up is going to be
it might be like rook b6 or something
here probably just the bishop c6 would
lock the rook in and then a5 and just at
least say hey you're freezing that
yeah this is one reason why i wanted f6
but um you can still do it even though
yeah
bishop g6 king g6 looks a little scary
but the king
perfectly safe
and that threatens bishop takes g6 yes
and then knight e5
so
[Music]
i think rook b6 and a5 has to be played
you need to like improve one of your
rooks anchor it in fix b7 your other
rook on b1 that's going to take some
time maybe rook b4 maybe a rook lift
there but like
uh white needs to maximize the remaining
pieces to find compensation and that
rook on b3 is not doing it it needs to
elevate up to b6 so it can look at the
f6 pawn coordinate with the queen on e1
a1 maybe the queen goes to a3 also at
some point well for now you also keep
your eyes open for tactics because
you know black is still very volatile
so a5 or knight h4 i'm predicting maybe
queen a3 to slowly bring the queen up i
like that
i think a5 is not mission critical yet
and it also gives a potential b5 square
for the bishop i would play queen a3 and
try to pan for gold along this diagonal
maybe swing the queen toward the center
to e3 no it's a versatile move you can
even go because queen a3 you might want
to go queen d3 check and do c4 then go
nate h4 check and you've forced the
pawns to commit
i would also consider queen c3 yes and
once again in trying to induce d4
queen d3 and that h4 operate along the
light squares
the time beginning to equalize though
nordervec is super tricky so uh i like
black's position a couple moves ago a
bit more but now it's like dynamic i
think white has compensation for the
pawn
right now
it's anybody's game
the open king and and some of the
activity
it's
it's very easy to blenders black here
right just the knight hopping around
um times even the evened up though and
there's no increment in armageddon we
remind you so easy to blunder move the
rook from b8 bang allow rook takes b7
just like that
i could see if i just have accidental
rook bd8 or something like that
and if i were him i would maybe move the
queen to
d7 notre brick's making some progress
here there's just a c is the time for a5
or do we go like queen f3 queen f3 i
think but queen f3 are you worried about
d4 or do you want d4 to happen
not sure more questions
i'll take on f6 then
and then sack the exchange
maybe
queen f5 is not out of the question he
wants to go queen h7 i think i think
that's the square for the queen so if
you don't go queen f5 now i think queen
h7 somehow it looks like a good move it
just
maybe you tried to optimize it a5 queen
h7 and then queen f5
yeah yep i can see that
but i don't see white winning that end
game unless it's on the clock
that's true right that's the win draw's
not okay so keep the queens on the board
then then i'm not going queen f5 i would
not i would not have faith with the
queens off so i'm telling myself keep
the queens on that's a path of no return
but what queen h7 is a lovely idea
and all the bases will be covered after
he plays it
notre back looking intently okay so
queen h7 queen f3
rook but that at that point i can play
rook bf8 that was the case
the defense of the queen side to my
bishop which is performing handsomely
there is the a5 move and i think we're
going to sequin h7 queen f5
and he's going to see his fortunes in
this game classy looking move
god my hands are shaking and i'm not
playing
tension builds up i think uh
people are wondering i think uh
abdusarov is playing a tournament right
now maybe turkish league or
where he's two out of two by the way
so so he's in a hotel room playing chess
during the day and playing chess during
the night like right now i think it's
around 1am probably in turkey
at least
okay had to say of taking his time queen
h7
is what we are anticipating
i was even considering
no
going crazy knight g6 check but
there's a the problem is that you're
down a pawn that's actually
a major problem in terms of the end game
yeah because those those rook end games
will be pretty clear-cut you're down
upon can you impact the pawn yeah but
past that
it's not looking uh not looking like
there's enough
and there it is
he took a while to play it though that
gives notre back another inkling of hope
in the end game
and queen f5 is what i'm anticipating
i'm guessing queen f3
the blue move or the green move or the
orange move
drum roll please
queen f3 rook fade that i can't solve
that problem
and yeah i i agree with that but
but he's got to make a decision yeah now
he's down on time now
it's just a blitz game at this point
you can see his eyes searching the board
for ideas
he has to win this game
a trip to the semifinals is on the line
happy to play that move but he felt he
had to keep the queens on
but uh
what about queenie oh no queenie four's
terrible i hang h6 don't listen to me um
i'm before terrified of d4 because
okay rook bc that's an idea
professionals
professional move first
and notre back stalling with c3 trying
to milk
every second is golden now
rook g4
at the same taking over the initiative
h3 don't be surprised to see g2
you're going to take
oh my god and she takes h4 is there a
win there
i i think i think there's at least a
draw which is what's necessary but rook
b c g8 is perfectly sufficient you
cannot take
the queen on h7 is so well placed uh
dania
good move by notre dame knight g2 knight
e3 or h3
d4
pedestal is smelling blood
opening up the bishop cd rook takes d4
yes rook takes d4 and queen e4 are both
ideas if c takes d4 is played
at this point i feel like
the question is whether black draws or
wins this i just don't see how nuterbeck
pulls the game out here
the bishop on c6 is now a monster and
the knight on g2 is dominated
so almost every category is now favoring
block time pieces material
i mean literally white is getting pushed
off the board with every move that i say
of accumulates and accumulates
and the time continues to dwindle he's
down in 90 seconds but he closes the
bishop down
um
maybe just rook two seven and then rook
to d7 rook g7 and then rook g to d7
rewrote the pieces rook g8 goes for the
sev but the problem rook t4 rook d4
queen b1 you blunder h6 again
that was a nervous move right there rook
2797 was a lot better
if white can win back upon
notre back is starting to emerge from
the grave he's walking out of that
cemetery again look at those pawns d4 f6
h6 all looking loose f3 closing down the
bishop
a bit of progress here maybe rook maybe
rook h4 maybe rook f4 and now the knight
has a path to e3 or f4 as well
all notorbik really wants is the time
scramble fetishive leaves f6 hanging but
he plans queen g7 in response
maybe rook f4 here you don't want to
trade queen so i'm not taking f6 maybe
rook f4 then knight g2 the knight h4
something like that what do you think
you have to be careful about d2 but you
can meet d2 with knight g2 that pawn is
under control
i'm thinking
slowly unravel
he's 20 seconds down all of a sudden and
he takes these three fearless from notre
back
i would not do that i would be afraid
well i'm already afraid rookie won then
roberto
i'm more worried about of notre beck's
clock than anything to navigate this
position with 40 seconds
is impossible you need to move for white
right now queen c1 get down to like 10
seconds queen c1 gotta attack h6 that's
the only target remaining so if rook
takes d3 the queen takes h6 check
then move the king
rook g4 oh rook choose four's mate he's
gotta move he doesn't see what to do
queen c1 quarterback's gonna flag
rook
smells blood
17 seconds he's got to move something
notablex gonna lose
rook d2 rook d2 you realize there's no
increment he's eric he's on eight
seconds it's over
but if a safe can literally go queen g7
i don't think he realizes increment i
don't
or his internet is down but he's
literally just flagging
oh my god
a fetishive seems confused too
and way too late to start pre-moving
it's over a pretty anti-climactic finish
but
very well deserved from betta sev
no i mean
played a risky opening
not everyone's style with black and
armageddon and uh handled the
complications extremely well
so i definitely think like even in the
final position even if white doesn't
lose on time
look at it right like black is out of
control trading off pieces
i think he was on his way to advancing
anyways and uh yeah well deserved
without question without question an
incredible armageddon no better way to
cap off a five-hour first
rcc finals day of action but do not
leave yet because
we need to draw some conclusions we need
to update you on the new bracket on the
winner's bracket on the losers bracket
because tomorrow will be day two of the
finals so go absolutely nowhere we'll
have the coinbase
uh recap and
some concluding thoughts on the other
side of the break here at the rapid
chess championship finals brought to you
by coinbase
[Music]
the rapid chess championship is brought
to you by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered you can earn
crypto by learning about crypto at
coinbase.com explore defy and web free
with your coinbase wallet get exclusive
rewards when you spend with your
coinbase card and much much more learn
more at
coinbase.com and get 10 in bitcoin when
you sign up and verify your account
check them out use the command sponsor
or command coinbase today and go to
coinbase.com to get that bitcoin baby
day one of the rapid chess championship
finals day one of four brought to you by
coinbase has concluded it was an epic
day of fireworks incredible battles time
scrambles swindles defensive resilience
attacking skill positional acumen we had
every skill and every player putting
everything out on the line and we will
have three more days of that but now it
is time for our coinbase rapid recap we
had a hard time choosing a game given
how many of them
there were today and how many good ones
there were today ultimately eric we
decided to go for hikaru nakamura's
first game against alexi serrano from
their quarterfinal matchup
it was to say that this game was
topsy-turvy is to say nothing eric
perhaps you could walk us through the
opening where the fireworks really begin
yeah no the players went for a pretty
sharp opening right from the start um
serrano playing blocky car going for
knight f3 e3 one of his systems
and if we just
fast forward a couple moves it's all
fairly normal bishop e2 bishop
f6
right f6 right here already is an
ambitious move indicating black wants to
play pawn to e5 next move
take the center and immediately start
pushing uh white's pieces back so that
already indicated there we were in for a
fight and your car was not one to
necessarily you know give up space space
for free so
um yeah wasn't an option no d4 was not
an option so that was the start of of
when things started getting spicy
c4 trying to undermine uh the center
then we had d4 b4
uh both both sides undermining the pawn
chains respectively
and when the dust settled here if we yep
after
this
position
yeah alexi was pretty happy here now
he's given up the bishop pair but this
is reminiscent of a reverse nimzo indian
samish variation that's a mouthful just
to say uh but black has complete control
of the d4 score the queen is largely
unassailable
and uh hikaru has a hard time
coordinating his pieces he plays bishop
a3 to prevent black from castling alexi
with a very well timed a7 a6 snags the
pawn on c4 fearlessly and we could sense
icaru getting uncomfortable here another
excellent move b5 this is tactical
wisdom by alexa here knight takes b5
runs into a check on e4 punishing white
for not castling bishop e3 queen g4
offering a queen trade and at this point
hikaru has an incredibly
uncharacteristic meltdown rather than
trading queens and getting into a
complicated end game he puts the knight
on d5 and eric
we cannot overstate the craziness the
insanity of this moment because the
queen takes you to a move that most
players would play in their sleep ends
the game on the spot hikaru just had a
brief mental lapse rook f1 knight takes
d5 rook takes c6 and among other things
bishop h3 wins a ton of material white
can resign in this position
we were sure that he would play it but
after a couple of seconds
queenie for check
i still can't believe it can you
i i can't believe that we call it the
hikaru effects where where players can
get psyched out or they don't expect
you know when you're playing a car that
you can make you blunt you know a
blunder because queen g2 as you
demonstrated wins
90 uh queenie for check which was played
instead
that allows the knight to retreat to e3
not only sheltering the king but
defending the pawn on g2 so once that
opportunity was missed there was no
further opportunity to to take away any
of you carlos king's side and now you
look at the position that we have right
here
black's king
in the center white's bishops bearing
down ikaru was in the driver's seat and
don't really think he let go for a while
there
dania no for a while i mean he played
quite decently we could spend an hour
just analyzing the intricacies
of this middle game but let's uh fast
forward a little bit as cicaro nurses
his initiative makes a couple of
inaccuracies and starts letting alexi
back into the game
with the move bishop b3 to
bishop b3 apologize for that uh to d5
and there were better moves this gives
alexia a chance to liquidate bishop c6
takes d5 and hiukara was banking on the
threat of a discover check against
black's queen might have forgotten that
alexi has the simple king f7
nikara was left to liquidate further
takes b5 knight c7 wins the rook back
after a preliminary check but alexi
dodging all the bullets walking his king
to d6 getting his rook into the game
white is still winning but at this point
the process has gotten a lot more
complicated and eric for a while alexi
keeps chipping away at hikaru's
advantage
yeah i mean you look at this position
black's king is starting to run back and
find a bit of shelter
and white has two isolated pawns the
pawn on d3 the pawn on a2 so despite
being up upon the quality of the pawns
favors black a little bit with that
continuous pawn chain and means that
hikaru had to spend time and energy
defending these pawn weaknesses which
allowed black to get back in the game
and pose some problems
and alexi continuing to centralize his
pieces up until the point when a nitrate
happens and queen d3 challenges hikaru's
queen forcing either a queen trait or
in the case of the game continuation
nikaru drops d4 material equalizes but
alexi facing imminent danger to his king
decides to
uh engage his strategic queen trade
giving up a pawn
but uh correctly assessing this end game
as objectively drawn but with only
seconds left on his clock you caught a
well-timed rookie two cutting off the
king and white's got this very easy plan
of dragging the king over to the queen
side and guiding the past pawn forward
and in time pressure alexi despite a lot
of good moves i think he started
correctly eric and he found the correct
idea of bringing the king to the center
but somewhere here he made a critical
mistake
yeah we were trying to assess this i
mean with perfect play can black hole
probably but in in practice in the game
you see that a pawn running down
at you your rook has to
back up and defend passively and then
you just have your lone king against
white's rook
who's going to win there well in the end
hikaru's rook stood firm on d2 and white
uh sorry black wasn't able to to collect
enough pawns to compensate for this
running a pawn that turned
turned turned into a queen shortly after
just just a couple moves behind but
that's all it takes well the last key
moment in cairo walking is king first to
the king side to collect four then back
to the queen side and alexi
one tempo short the problem is that you
can never play king g2 because of the
check so he has to wait for the white
king to leave but by the time it does
you're one tempo too late the king to be
seven it goes and rook takes a seven
would have been a draw if icaru had to
take with the rook but obviously here he
can take with the king defending
the remaining pawn and alexi resigned
shortly thereafter a monumental victory
for hikaru he survived the second game
as well despite a dubious position to
make his way into the semi-finals of the
winner's bracket and this ladies and
gentlemen was our coinbase critical uh
was our coinbase a recap for the day
apologies it's been a long day indeed
and uh
as evidence that it's been a hog day let
us take a look at the updated and
annotated bracket eric
uh it almost seems like the round one
matches were played in a different era
yeah we were today we saw yeah and they
were today that was like many hours ago
i thought you were referring to some of
the games in their style that there's a
bit of romantic chess there is that two
big games some open games that maybe
morphy would have been proud of but yeah
it has been a long day and there's been
a ton of fighting chess
really really some of the absolute best
rapid players in the world
went at each other's throats this is an
elimination and
look at that field in the loser's
bracket
i mean
there's a world monsters tiger sharks
there's a reigning world rapid champion
there
there's the next world championship
challenger there
i mean
look it's just it is just stacked i'm
excited for both the losers bracket and
the winners
we just did that recap i thought it was
a good one because i mean hikaru i think
he's determined favorite and that was
his closest rush with death today
and hikara will definitely have more
brushes with death because he is playing
the winner of fedex nepam nishi yana
pamyushi has demonstrated excellent form
uh in the last week of the rcc and at
the start of these four-day finals so
both brackets both the losers and the
winners they can be confused for each
other you could look at both brackets
and you wouldn't be able to determine
which would be the losers and which
would be the winners tomorrow friday
august 19th at the same start time 12
eastern 9 a.m
pacific we will have the losers round 1
and 2 as well as the winners semi-final
so we will have three batches of
excellent games as those in the losers
bracket have no more margin for error
left they have to win out in order to
challenge the winner of the winners
bracket in the grand final the finals
last four days the start time will be
the same each of those four days so
we hope that you have cancelled all of
your plans called in sick
prophylactically just so you can stay
home and watch i am a great influence
and watch the rapid chess championship
finals but for now
eric i will pass you the mic one more
time for your
final conclusions about this epic day of
rcc action
before i wrap up
no i just i just had a fun time
commentating a couple moments stand out
for me i mean
the stalemate uh trick that was
available in the abdu'sadarov game fedo
saves tactics we had uh
the ding and and jeffrey match that
featured some of the finest i think uh
sportsmanship uh
that i've i've ever seen uh in a top
level game
you had you had quite a few uh moments
today so i mean i just had a blast i
hope everyone does uh book off the next
few days
to come come watch the show
i'll be i'll be happily in the audience
but daniel it was uh it was a pleasure
as always
likewise eric this these five hours
passed so so quickly it was a pleasure
commentating with you and i'd like to
take this opportunity to thank the chat
and everybody on youtube twitch
uh watching and supporting your favorite
player the rcc would not be possible
without such a steady base of supporters
keeping the chat active and energized of
course to our sponsors coinbase uh and
hired for making the rcc finals possible
and to our producer matt who worked
tirelessly
to produce excellent graphics and for
another flawless broadcast and now
for everyone on our wonderful chess.com
team our producer matt grandmaster eric
hanson i am grandmaster daniel
naredinsky saying goodbye from the rapid
chest championship presented by coinbase
we will see you tomorrow for day two of
the finals
and gentlemen the time has come it is
thursday and that means it is the start
of the rapid chess championship finals
presented by coinbase the next four days
are going to be chock full of incredible
action as 16 players compete for the
crown of this inaugural rcc season rook
takes c7
uh-oh he's having some issues because
all these things should be automatic
this is really really really bad oh my
god oh my gosh she's down in three
seconds
oh no
and jeffrey is not gonna feel good about
winning a game like that oh that is
tragic
ren uh managed to reconnect the game
began and jeffrey i think has resigned
the game classy is to say nothing
jeffrey giving ding the second game so
they will go to armageddon queen f2
queen f2 rook after rook c4 try to put
the rook on a4 feels like very close to
just the fourth straw there i think
jeffrey's got this in the bag hats off
to jeffrey because uh the sportsmanship
and then letting his chest speak for
himself i think i'm drake and blender to
peace oh we have to go there people love
seeing the blunders because they can
relate oh
whoa
what that
what was i think that's like a hikaru
effect or something like that move i
cannot explain that is a
mind-bogglingly bad move well this can
be from the player of his class
alexa not now that's it
oh my god wait whoa
oh the king can hide on the h-file
the king can head on the h file oh
because black has the h pawn oh so
there's no checks
that's what he was going for alexi had
to push his pawn rather than
procrastinating oh
he is upset g5 and five thick
[Music]
it's over
sasha is not gonna play another move and
alexis arana huge kudos to him upset
tough last game he keeps his composure
very difficult position and he turns
around and beats alexander grisham
by the way we have a photo of wesley
so's chess setup i'm
getting neural
overload circuit short circuiting now
wesley could sack the queen but he's not
going to do it because the knight can
land on f6 on demand oh
whoa
whoa whoa whoa rook takes f4 does he
want rook takes b2 he does i get it
carl blundered a piece or no
queen takes g2
he's gonna play queen g2 danya
oh my god the hikaru effect strikes
again
this is unbelievable
no you i didn't i
still think some people
they're still made oh the king is
stalemated black just gives away all of
his pieces
bishop f7 was a howler of biblical
proportions
bring the knight to e3 use all your
pieces jeffrey needs to make sure he's
back at the computer he's uh maybe
taking a bathroom break or just thinking
about what to play because it's a
dilemma what do you play against wesley
when you need to win on-demand
another gracious move wesley added
time back to jeffrey's clock he added
added until he had ten
some feel good moments today
[Music]
so
you